Oh, I was like, are we in the bad timeline?
Wait, what?
Are we not live?
Oh, wait, what happened?
Are we live now?
Oh, shit, we're live now.
Oh, wait, what the fuck happened?
What?
like oh my god I had an entire tangent I had an entire tangent and like it was the intro was looping and everything that's so weird it actually okay um that is so weird I okay so anyway sorry I'm right now I'm trying to figure out who the fuck is Dominic and try because uh tangent wants me to invite it.
We figured out how to do invites on Gears of War, but then he was the one that invited me.
No, he's not.
I didn't call him yet because I'm going to roast him a little bit.
so, he invited me and then so he was the one that figured out how to do the invites, but it took us a while.
It took us like 10 to 15 minutes to figure out how to do invites.
And then, but then we have to restart our game because we want to change our settings.
I was like, alright, invite me.
And he was like, well, I want to be Dominic.
I'm like, who the fuck is Dominic?
So now I'm trying to figure out how to do the invites because he's playing on the Xbox app and I'm playing it on Steam.
So like, it's very, very tilting right now.
I'm so fucking confused.
So I'm trying to figure this out right now.
It's so weird.
Like, when you're trying, when you're trying to, playing cross platforms on the xbox app versus uh uh xbox app versus uh steam on steam also um the reason why we're like super late also another reason why we're super late yeah he got on the game pass because it's free on the game pass but um the reason why we're super late was i just got my pc back and because i just got my pc back uh i was getting upgrades done because i was like i was really like tilted with all the lag and stuff especially like i was lagging in minecraft so i I need to like actually like look into this and so this is like basically my stress test right now um because now I have four sticks of ram and a new CPU and if you guys do not oh do I have VOD replay on oh my gosh I'm such a fucking mess right now I'm not VOD replay off I have now restricted VOD replay look I'm I'm a I'm a fucking mess right now because like uh I literally got back my PC at um 450 at 450 and I had to plug everything in and uh and um so if you
guys don't follow me I'll give I'll tell the story with tension um because he's gonna be like what the fuck um but basically what happened was that I got scammed on my CPU I bought an AMD CPU I'm rewinding and she can't stop me but yeah I bought an AMD CPU online and they gave me an Intel card
so I had to buy another new CPU at the local at my local shop to fix the issue I can't tension invite me I can't do it I can't find you on the Microsoft shit I don't know if he's watching my stream okay I'm gonna let me see if I can do it through my Xbox app but like I don't understand I'm so confused okay invite to game is that it invite to party uh oh no that's not it how the do you do i don't use the xbox app just invite um you're not playing dominic i don't you're not playing dominic because i don't understand the the invite system
on steam I have to invite him through the because like I can't find him through the fucking steam list all right let's see it the steam system is so confusing I don't understand okay I'll show you guys because that's like my entire friends list and and that like I have like real-life friends on my friends list I can't show you guys the friends list all right I don't understand so he's not he's not playing Dominic sucks to be him I will not understand I refuse to learn anyway my steam is linked to my xbox app but it won't show me like xbox friends for some reason I don't know why he's not picking up wait joinable joinable invite oh invite only how do I do that well I can do invite only joinable okay join up open to friends okay there you go now open to friends.
Then he could join me, right?
Hey, try to join me.
I opened my lobby.
What do you mean I'm not playing Dominic because you don't understand the advice?
I don't understand the system!
You're not all my friendless!
I can't!
I'm a team!
It doesn't really matter.
They're both literally the same guy.
It doesn't matter.
Dude, how dare you?
How dare you?
No!
They're basically beefy men with chainsaw guns.
like does it really matter like do i have it actually matters do you not do you do you not want to play as jake from adventure time i don't know who they are i just watched my dad play this game when i was like you know this game came out in 2006 i was a very small child when this game came out i don't you think i understand i'm spamming you okay nice for let me see if i wait maybe i can figure this out okay no i can't i actually cannot i literally have friends on xbox and one of it is you oh i accidentally clicked streamed oh no now i'm streaming this game on tell him it matters the game on okay play here wait i actually clicked that i wanted to stream the game and i don't want to stream the game oh no okay what i i don't understand the xbox app this fucking sucks this app sucks microsoft if you sponsor me i won't say your app sucks
okay wait wait wait i'm trying to wait i'm trying to i said i was gonna i i clicked stream the game and i don't want it oh whatever we'll figure this out later okay give me a sec i'm getting your foogie i'm getting your foogie give me a sec your oh she's blind i'm not blind what you mean i'm literally in the game i'm in the game in your party right now how am i blind okay let me i'm grabbing your your little foodie right now for god's sake uh
all right you want to hear a story of how i got scammed yesterday well it wasn't yesterday okay so so basic okay guys also sound check do i sound check people right now i sound check on my end how does sound check how does everyone sound uh let me see where is gears award oh yeah there's no one at home right now and it's in the morning so I can scream the fuck how much I want.
By the way, TTZ is Tengen.
Um, it's not some random person that joined.
I am not paying $10 to change my name.
Yeah, he doesn't want to pay $10 to change his name.
So TTZ is Tengen because, uh, it was linked to his Microsoft account.
Um, so that's why.
Uh, so now this is like my halo.
Today, yesterday, well, I bought this.
See, I bought an AMD CPU like two months ago in June, but I procrastinated in, uh, changing my CPU.
and I bought it off of Amazon.
I bought it online because I was like, the CPU I wanted to use was not at my local shop.
So I was like, I'll just order it online.
And I double checked it with my friends.
I was like, it's just the right listing.
And they're like, yeah, and it's from the official AMD listing.
And then I prime deliver it.
And then I, yesterday, I finally opened the CPU package and inside was an Intel card.
and not only was it an intel card it was an intel card from 15 years ago and it was still attached to it motherboard so it was cut out from its fucking motherboard and then people and i tweeted about it yeah inside by the way it was official packaging and everything and it was this intel card was made in Costa Rica too by the way i'll send you a photo yeah it was oh it was from Costa Rica I just saw this.
I just saw this.
Like, do you see the photo?
Yes.
Yeah, yeah.
Like, at the bottom is literally the motherboard.
Jesus Christ.
At the bottom of that card is literally the motherboard that it's attached to.
Like, for those that don't follow me on Twitter, this was, yes.
But the thing is, I didn't notice because the packaging, it was all like authentic packaging, like with the stickers and everything.
and then i and that's how i by the user card that's how i found out that there is this scam that people pull on amazon where they order like pc parts and then they'll like use like a they return it yeah they use these heater things to remove like the packaging stuff so it doesn't look like they ripped the packaging and everything and then like they put it they they do a switcheroo with an old cpu which but mine is a fucking 15 plus year old cpu like yeah zion and intel zion on my amd amd package and and then they like return it intel yeah and then they return it and the amazon doesn't double check and because it's past the 30-day window this cpu is 999 canadian dollars by the way this is a nine it was a 999 Canadian like Canadian dollars for this cpu I can't even get a refund because is past the 30 days and then they're like and then like they're like sorry we don't make any exceptions and i'm going i'm gonna do a chargeback on them at my bank i'm gonna do a chargeback that is fucking
bullshit that's not a hundred median dollars what because because i didn't know that was this is the first time i've ever got how do you procrastinate because like i didn't have I've been busy with my PC because I was like, you know what?
Everything seems to be okay.
I don't really need to upgrade yet.
But then like yesterday, I did a Minecraft stream, and I was lagging during my Minecraft stream.
So I was like, okay, I should do my upgrades now because I'm actually lagging.
Like, I don't care when are you going to swap it.
It's just that you really not have the urge to open your package as soon as you're like, why do you not need that?
I don't even know how to insert my RAM because the last time I inserted my RAM I Accidentally fried my RAM
So I never and then and then the second and then when I went to get new RAM the person sold me faulty RAM So then I so then I and the third time I get to go back to the shop at the fucking I just lugged my PC to them I like you insert this RAM.
I give up.
I literally I gave up at that point because I was like nothing works for me I am hyperventilating just so you know Like you don't understand I have so many issues with PC parts So like I just don't trust myself I literally just got sent a fucking intel card from Costa Rica Like
Like how could this And then when I told people they're like Are you sure the local shop didn't like You know like your PC building didn't like do a switcher rose like no i literally opened this from my package and this was the card like like how i and like one of my friends was like i've never seen that happen before this is the first time i've ever seen someone got scammed online like got scammed for a pc part yeah oh i'll probably get bad from you should check your packages bro i probably get bad from amazon if I do a chargeback it's not what they're oh my god I can't even do that is unrelatable because we don't have Amazon they get to keep $900 from me but those who are like you got scammed because it was nine no because the retail price for the AMD I don't know 9,000
whatever the fuck it's called is like around that price I don't even remember what it was called and I had prime on it so it gave me like a slight discount um I don't yeah but like it was like a it's a beefy fuck CPU um but apparently so like what I imagine so it's it's 900 bucks yeah what I found out was that they uh they basically like uh it's in a warehouse and they just merge all the merge all the like uh package like they put return the package doesn't seem like it's open after it's return,
you just ship it to new customers.
That's so fucked up.
I was like, I can't believe.
That's fucked up.
Yeah, I can't believe they would do that.
They would just, because they're like, oh, it's not open.
It's not open, so it's basically new.
It's basically new.
It's not open.
Also, are any of my mods alive?
I was like, sound check, and none of my mods responded.
I don't know if my mods are alive.
Also, give me a sec.
I want to grab a drink real quick, Tension.
Oh, God.
Yeah.
Oh my god, what the fuck?
Oh god.
Save you guys.
I don't know if...
Oh god, what the fuck?
Ugh!
I have never ordered anything from Amazon because I don't...
We don't have Amazon here.
So...
Yeah.
about return policy no return policy it's like 30 days so i because i i got it i got in june and it's all almost the end of the august so it's because like the thing here about packages oh yeah here you get tax i always open it i always open it because i don't trust the delivery process yeah the traffic in indonesia is as dangerous as it can get because one time i like like a motherboard a cpu and a ram and this is like a fucking instant courier type shit this is like um we get like food delivered with a person on a motorcycle basically right yeah but you can yeah but you can do that shit for like items as well so they will personally deliver those items to you the way it's like uber eats basically so it's literally within hours and one time i ordered that shit my guy fucking crashed what i lost contact in a guy for like a good eight hours where the is this guy because it is a guarantee that the package will arrive within three hours and thank god nothing happened to the package but
holy is the guy all right what about the person like i i legit like like the person who delivered it was a different guy and he was like oh you had the guy crash oh yeah but Is he all right?
He's in the ER.
Is he all right?
I thought like, what the fuck?
Whoa, stop trauma dumping, man.
I just want my package.
So fucked up.
It's crazy.
He's, no, he's not crushed.
He crashed.
No, he got, he crashed.
It was like a car crash or something.
The accident.
It's, it's, it's a motorcycle accident.
It happens every two hours here, probably.
Minor ones.
I mean, because there's a lot of motorcycles there, right?
Yeah.
Very much.
yep guys someone was like just do a chargeback who cares about an amazon account i care i want my twitch prime you guys know if you have twitch prime you can subscribe to any of your favorite streamers on twitch uh i guess and guess who has a twitch right now i also have a twitch hot dokey breed um at twitch so you can subscribe to your favorite streamer for free hey
yikes on my channel More people to advertise to.
Okay, what do you want?
I'll let you plug.
I'll give you one free plug.
Subscribe to me and join my membership.
Yeah, his channel is Jokey Bird at YouTube.
Nah.
Okay, Kenjin can come down a little bit.
Okay, all right.
All right, let me lower you down just a little bit then.
all right i lowered him a little bit so what's he i hope he wasn't too loud when i was talking about my fucked up story about my card i still can't believe i still can't believe like they gave me a fucking 15 year old cpu and at least give me a 15 year old cpu that's amd like i at least give
You paid for your AMD.
Well, you got an Intel.
Yeah, the fact that I got an Intel card is so...
For 15 years ago.
Damn.
Yeah, now I...
The fact that it's still on the motherboard is crazy.
Yeah, it literally was attached.
They literally just cut it out of the motherboard.
And then people in my...
In my...
When I tweeted it out, people were like, yeah, they don't...
You can't even get this.
You can't even get that anymore.
You have to, like, order it off of eBay.
of it's still attached to a motherboard to even get this processor.
Like, this is like, what?
Yeah.
And they're like, yeah, it's not even sold publicly.
It's literally a workstation card.
Like, I don't have no idea how to fuck this person you have access to it, but it's not even sold to, this card isn't even sold to a, it's not even sold to the public.
Someone's like, sell it to a collector.
It's worth $20.
It's, the card is worth $20.
Like, I can't even do anything.
anything with it uh i gotta wait another 50 years before i can sell this card before it's literally worth anything i gotta wait auction that a cpu yeah i gotta wait 50 years or it's not even a card it's a processor yeah your processor just signed it auction it all put it somewhere don't keep her signed yeah i'll just sign it's worth it's i mean it's useless all right sound guys everything okay now everything all right how is my end yeah is tension does tension sound okay now he wasn't drowning me out during story time right the next joki charity auction the cpu she was scammed with that works honestly i'll just yeah i can sign in the back on the fucking motherboard at the back i'm pretty sure you can't even do anything with it because it's it's literally like just like attached to the motherboard like i don't know even know if you can use it for anything uh i mean if they cut it out of the motherboard that means it's in a locked state and they didn't even bother to unlock the cpu so
i'm pretty sure they did it so it'll weigh more i'm pretty sure so so like it'll weigh like the same as like the original cpu yeah that's actually crazy okay do i do like you're you invited me so you're the one the campaign right i don't know okay host co-op i don't want to be dumb well too bad you're not gonna be dumb i don't know how to use the i don't know how to use the invite no can you can you host the campaign i literally i can't because you're the leader no no i really cannot no i really did i tried i tried you can only access this access give me the squad leader give me squad leader but it just hold on give me squad leader you have the crowd just say it's mute block use your property i guess i'm sorry man i can't buy the game on steam oh my god i don't know how to i don't know how to add people i tried it just give me all right all right let's let's start all right see i hope we they gave us a selection i hope okay yeah what difficulty uh well we're not we're sort of gamers so
like easy maybe there's casual normal hardcore and I feel like we can do hardcore.
Like, we both play video games.
So I feel like we can do hardcore.
Alright.
Okay.
Hardcore.
Creating match.
Are you fucking doubting yourself?
Are you scared?
I... Yeah.
You used to be a pro player and you're scared.
What happened to you, man?
What the fuck happened to you?
I'm lost.
Bro, you...
What?
Weren't you just in a tournament like last week or some shit?
Oh, yeah!
Yeah, fucking I'm washed.
Why is the game so loud on my end?
Holy shit!
Wow, seriously.
Alright, oh, wait, these graphics look good.
Oh, you fart.
Oh, my God, it's so loud.
I'm turning this game down.
It is.
Why is the cutscene not toned down?
My ears.
Oh, there's...
Oh, hey, that's dumb.
All right.
What are you doing here?
Getting you out.
Oh, so that's Dom.
That's the guy you want to be?
Yes.
What's wrong with Marcus?
He seems pretty cool.
I just can't unhear Jake from Adventure Time whenever he talks.
Oh, yeah.
Wait, I want to be Jake.
That's what I'm saying.
I want to be Jake.
That's what I'm saying!
Oh, the game audio is low.
Okay, give me a sec.
Holy shit.
Dude, my audio is on too.
Everything is so loud.
It sounds so loud, though, for me.
Alright, let's see.
I need a...
Okay, keyboard and mouse.
I'm using keyboard and mouse, by the way.
There's nothing.
Okay, let's see.
Cutscene volume.
Nothing like that off the sort.
I think cutscene volume has to be just like...
It has to be just like...
What was it?
uh voice dialogue isn't it all right here sound guy look at this sound guy i'll just put this on one also i lower attention a little bit more i'm gonna put that oh sweet sweet sweet okay all right oh yeah i'm testing a new mouse pad i got wall hack sent me like uh oh my god i'm not lagging wall hack sent me a uh their their glass pad like the newest one wall hacks glass pads and i tried glass pad it's so fast i'm not used to it at all so who am i am i dom or jake you're you're dom i'm jake okay no wonder yeah no wonder yeah no for you what just happened what the takes time but it's safe or we can go through the prison blocks and get right into the fight your choice what do you want to do wait why can't i move no no no no oh you're like i'm picking a path wait how come you get to pick that's why i'm telling you that's not fair why are you the main characters that's what i was saying i want to be dumb there should be equal equal rights equal choices i should be able to vote wow okay it's
not as dumb i should be able to choose who i want to where i want to go there's an option combat or training we i feel like we play this game.
Also, I need to, wait, let me up the volume a little bit more for my game.
Alright.
We gotta train.
We, I don't know how to play this game.
We gotta go train.
Alright.
Training it is.
I gotta work out the kinks.
That's good, man.
That's crazy.
Wait.
Wait, don't listen to sound like Jake.
I wanna be Jake!
It's not fair!
Wait a minute.
I thought I was Jake.
No, I'm Jake.
That's why I'm on free.
That's why I want to be dumb.
Like, I don't want to be Jake.
I don't want to be Jake.
He's so...
That's literally Bender from Futurama.
Yeah.
All right.
I, uh, I'm up the volume.
Huh.
Man, who I was here to get you?
I'd be in some deep shit.
Come on.
Let's go.
All right.
I can't believe it.
He gets to be Jake and the main character.
What's the shift, dude?
Team still feels well.
Okay, don't worry.
I'll up the volume again.
All right.
I should up the brightness.
Give me a sec.
Oh, yeah.
No, I up the brightness a little bit too.
It's so dark.
Oh, my God.
Why is it there?
All right.
I up the volume again.
I swear to God, if I have to restart for the fucking brightness.
I swear to God.
That is so washed.
All right.
Oh, no, it's just my OBS.
Give me a sec, guys.
Oh, it's just...
Are you playing through your OBS?
Like, what the fuck?
No, there's a color correction on my OBS.
in case if things are too dark.
Alright, there you go.
Okay.
Alright.
Oops.
I forgot there's limited ammo.
Alright, where do we go?
Oh, fuck.
I forgot the reload.
I forgot the reload QTE.
Wait, there's a reload QTE?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Reload.
Oh, I see it.
Yeah, yeah.
Reload.
Okay, where do we go?
I think this way?
I don't know.
I wasn't paying attention!
Okay, maybe up.
Maybe up.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I was not paying attention at all.
Administration?
Me too, because the game is so fucking loud.
Yeah, yeah, see, this is the guards quarters.
Security door button, press it.
It's on the dash.
Press it.
Yeah.
Surely nothing will go wrong when you...
The music is so fucking loud.
Surely nothing will...
You can turn the music down.
It's on one!
What?
It's too thick to cut.
So I was like, who is he?
Is it her brother?
Yeah, my brother from Indonesia.
I'm her Indonesian brother.
Yeah.
You wanted to work out the kings?
This is the place to do it.
Yeah, I'm working out the kings, man.
All right.
Where do we go?
I guess we go here.
Wait, there's something over here.
Can I jump over?
Nice.
I have legs.
all right did give me this audio this audio sucks bro holy the music is so loud i'm tuning it from the windows mixer sound from the window mixer sound okay i hope not getting volume a little bit more guys if it's any better okay i also lower tension a little bit more if everything is good Let me know.
There you go.
This is better now.
Holy fuck.
Like, the music's drowning and everything.
Oh, wait.
There's a Lucas.
Take cover.
Hello?
Wait, he's not even peeking me.
I'm going in.
Wait, what's my HP?
I can't even see.
What's my HP?
Your HP.
Is it like Battlefield?
I think you're good.
the hp like battlefield where like as long as your if your screen is red then like you have no hp jesus maybe everything will go oh hey oh they closed the door open it up dom oh wait i'm dumb open it up you're gone what do you mean do it again open it oh press the button and now stand next to it oh my god it's teamwork we got this is it is it yeah do you know oh press oh oh my god There was a button right here,
wasn't there?
Why don't you press it?
You press it.
You're dumb.
You're literally the main character.
Do your job.
I'm Jake from Adventure Talk.
You're literally the main character.
Oh my God.
What the fuck?
Nice.
What the hell's been going on in this prison?
Dude.
You want to know.
You think it's okay?
Insurance will cover that.
Yeah, insurance will cover that, right?
Don't worry.
We're not in America.
Well, I hope you don't get split open.
Yeah, I hope.
But, where do we...
Oh, what's this?
Oh, grenades.
How do I grab here?
Got them.
Wait, you get to hold grenades and I can't...
Oh, there.
Okay, never mind.
We should just grab it.
It didn't give me the command!
Okay, how do I use it?
Is it G?
It's four.
It's four?
Why the fuck is it four?
There's multiple...
Friendly fire?
Watch out!
I like how we both walked up to it and tested our life.
Okay, yeah, there's friendly fire.
Okay, okay, we know now.
Friendly fire.
We have to test it out.
Get a frag in there.
Oh my god, definitely you turned down my sense to use glass pad.
This glass pad is so fast.
We are moving your location.
Over.
we are clearing area for extraction is the game audio better guys wait how did you roll i mean you're gonna be surprised when sprinting is space oh wait really wait i just did a twirl it's i can't even jump guys you think that's a bad person over there okay i'm gonna throw
don't worry i have more okay it's taking yeah i know i they're taking forever yeah i timed it okay so i don't have like any grenades left we're okay these noobs no way no way um excuse me we're playing on hardcore so we can't be noobs
It can't be news if we're playing out hardcore.
Oh my god, like...
And then someone in my chat is going to be like, yeah, but you're not playing on Insane.
Okay.
Oh my god, please.
QTE reload.
Come on, let me reload.
Okay.
QTE reload.
I passed my QTE.
Where is everybody?
Where's the others?
Insane is easy.
Yeah, they're bad.
This looks like an easy game.
It's pretty easy game.
Should be.
Can you do the QTE?
You think those people up top will be okay?
Yeah.
Probably.
Insurance will cover that.
Yeah, exactly.
Don't worry.
I'm pretty sure they have a good insurance policy.
All right.
I need to lower my sense.
I'm going to break the immersion right now.
I need a lower Wait, you can move while I'm paused But I can't when you're paused That's so fucked up But where are my rights as a player too I have no rights I actually have zero rights as the second player It's so fucked up That's why I want to be dumb I like being the second player I passed the game on insane when I was 12 Oh my god That means you're old That's the main character privileges.
Damn.
Oh, shit.
That's the point of being played.
Lights are over.
He didn't even game, someone said.
He has a mask.
That means he's gonna die.
That's me!
No, I'm Marcus.
Wait, I'm, oh yeah, I'm Dom.
I can't.
I keep forgetting who I am!
They look the same!
Both big rugged men!
Big, big rugged men.
They don't have hats for me to tell difference.
Trader like you doesn't deserve to wear the uniform.
Wait, what?
He's a trader?
He just sounds like Jake, bro.
I can't.
I've got good news.
We have a plan to end this.
Oh, we have a plan.
Oh, wait.
I don't have a hat.
Oh, that's how I tell the difference.
Yes, you have a beard.
Yeah, okay, look at the faces.
It's literally the same thing.
Oh, shit.
Look at this.
Take cover.
See, the girl didn't die.
She was too pretty.
Holy shit.
She spent too much time modeling her so she can't kill her.
Cutscene audio is so fucking huge.
but it can't work if we don't have the targeting data that's why we need the resonator the resonator so that we can hit those sons of where they live what's the point of yeah what's the point of wearing helmets if you're just gonna die from a headshot that's true yeah see that's why real men don't wear helmets in game guys in game in game
We have air support.
What?
Are you kidding?
You are the support, son.
You are the support.
Nemesis are keeping our birds out of the area.
You'll have to move in on foot.
We're screwed.
Damn right, we are.
The lieutenant here will be feeding you intel.
Yes, sir.
And the smart thing to do right now would be to leave.
Leave is not...
It's not running away.
It's relocating you a better position.
relocation it's not relocation for you we're not running away we're relocating yes enemy reinforcements all right okay sound effects need to be lowered a little bit i still can't believe it doesn't pause the game when i'm playing it that one was on the house all right except get up those stairs all right let me know if this sounds better sound guys all right i'm coming over don't worry very slow don't worry I'm getting there look I have so much equipment on right now nice okay man here we go oh yeah I guess to use the chainsaw how do you how do you do that F wait it's time to play the real game where are they
Wait, you also just ran at him?
Oh, I'm dying.
It's like I got you.
Wait, where are you?
No.
Who?
Wait, that's my teammate.
Oh, there you are.
Get up.
Dump.
Wait, no, I'm dumb.
Get up.
Your nose.
I'm just hanging out.
I can't remember.
I got him first.
Oh, you said.
I was like, cover-based shooter we don't need cover where I come from we grab these bullets that you don't need all right time to remember remember what my sick-ass chainsaw damn whoa cover is optional exactly I did not pay $40 to go take
You got this game for free.
I guess you can do whatever the fuck you will.
I mean, technically it's not free.
What do you mean?
You got it off of the game pass.
Yeah, well, I still believe in the game pass.
Marcus, plank left.
Don't worry.
Oh, shit.
Oh, it's not going to stop me.
It's not going to stop me.
Holy shit.
You think a bullet would stop my tanky body?
Let's go.
you're just chainsawing everything right now i got smacked in the head i might need help yeah he he let me chainsaw his buddy before i know you can't die please i can't i can't have the consequences of my actions yay no no liability no consequences of my actions all right free with a fee cover is optional exactly
okay where are they i don't see them is that that's my guy crosshair turns red i can't help it they look just like the locust they're built just like them oh i up my i i up my quick time event oh no i was not using cover don't worry i believe in you i believe i'm right here i'm right here never punished you guys i think i might need i think i might need to start using cover maybe i'm not sure maybe maybe huh look they're all big beefy men it's so hard to tell which one is my beefy man and which one is their beefy man which one's the suddenly what the fuck you can literally press shift and see your teammate not the mpcs the mpcs look the same that that's crazy you wear a uniform where the fuck is the emergency hold the bodies oh maybe behind us is it behind us oh he just opened the door for us for What the fuck?
Why does it check the bodies when he can just do that?
All beeping men are good men.
They're not evil.
They're just misunderstood.
You're right.
Misunderstood Barra.
Damn.
Alright, where do we go?
Quick time.
Where are they?
Oh, that's you shooting them.
Go tangent, go, I believe in you.
I'm hoping.
Yeah, I'm sure.
Look, I'm just with the...
You're not even taking cover.
Um, taking damage instead of taking cover.
Is there crouch in this game or no?
No, you can walk.
Okay, cool.
Yeah, I get to use my legs.
Oh, oh my god, okay.
Oh, I got TP'd.
I was like, what the fuck?
Okay, oh, nice.
It's fine.
I'm dying.
You're fine.
Just rest me.
Live and rest me.
Wait, I can run.
How do you run?
Where the fuck are you?
I'm here.
Wait, how do you run?
I know what?
You can.
Okay, you're just walking right into him.
Yeah, what the fuck?
Wait, how do you run?
Space.
That's the role, isn't it?
Oh, no.
It's...
Oh, what?
Okay, these controls are...
Okay.
okay these mouth controls are weird they never bothered to change the fucking controls yeah yeah they didn't they didn't bother to optimize the working control yeah run is literally space bar yeah i was like yep oh my god it's so wonky though too because like it it like uh drifts a little oh cut scenes fishing a bear well it could be alpha cog tags are gone is that the resonator now i would love to use controller but i literally can't aim on a controller marcus what do you think what do i think it could be alpha who's that was jake setting a trap he's jake yeah it's jake when before he got before he got
meant re what's it called reable unicorn uh his wife yeah before he met his korean wife he wasn't a warrior no i am not okay it's a mirror by not like hitting any shots on that guy like no you have to real legit take cover so that the accuracy is better like it's a mirror not taking any damage like i swear to god my my crosshair is is fact honest.
Where's Carmine?
I don't know.
Oh, he's right here.
Don't worry, I'll pick him up.
He's good to go.
What the fuck?
Oh, wait, I have no ammo.
Okay, it's time to use.
Okay, don't worry.
I got smacked to death.
Wait, are you okay?
Oh my god, he's right over here.
Don't worry.
I'm not okay.
He'll eventually die.
Don't worry.
There we go.
We got him!
It took 20 years, but we...
Our NPCs don't res.
The AI don't res.
I failed QTE!
This QTE is so annoying.
Maybe you are watched.
How do you fail the QTE?
I play too much.
We are chat, maybe.
Behind us.
It's fine.
I'm just gonna... Oh shit, I failed the QTE.
I failed the QTE.
Just change him nice i'll steal the bullets going i need bullets oh i hear more locusts in front of us yep
right why aren't they taking cover i don't understand oh oh give me cover take cover take cover wait it's just one guy you kill him no you did not kill him I'm reloading I'm trying to get out of cover all right jump ammo ammo give me ammo holy shit yeah bullets now yeah your 100 bullets remaining 500 I may or may not have taken oh wait that's our guy you I can't tell they wear the same clothes Yes,
they do!
What are you on about, man?
They literally...
Oh my, they look so similar.
Like, it's just... Oh, it's just darker gray or lighter gray.
That's their uniform.
Dude, the...
The fucking vibration is crazy in this game.
Are you... Wait, are you playing on your controller?
No, the fucking screen shake, you know?
Oh, you turn that off.
You can?
Yeah, that's literally the first thing I turn off.
I always look for screen shake.
immersion but i hate i hate immersion hold on where is it sorry i forgot player two has no our camera shake player two has no right thank you very much i was getting his own oil by it literally when i pause nothing you get to keep playing the game
okay he's dead i got him my gun jammed man give me a sec figured wait is there a friendly fire ow I'm taking shot from somewhere it's not me I know it's hard to believe but it wasn't me oh there's another one oh I can't ping I think did you take damage there not quite oh fuck okay oh I got jammed I got jammed I didn't realize I was reloading get out oh my god the AI will block you when you try to get out of cover I'm sealing the hole you're sealing what you can do that throw frags there's more holes do much more holes throw frags in there oh shit wait where's Marcus I'm down where's Marcus where are you pre-shift oh my god why are you over there i was sealing the holes can you crawl over no i can't this is a modern game no crawling isn't really invented just crawl over it's just that easy just crawl oh no you must be referring to the popular game called apex legends from here okay oh i might die for this i might die for this the way i got you all right now you rest me now God,
that's dumb.
If it works, it works.
I jab my gun.
Where's Kim?
Kim is, like, literally in the center right now.
Holy shit, Kim is right here.
Yeah, he is so fucked.
He's, like, literally in the middle of two locusts.
I got one.
Oh, Kim's still on his own.
What the fuck?
That's bullshit.
What is this?
A saw rifle.
I don't even know what gun I just got.
what the hell don't worry guys we're okay you'd think we would have figured out some kind of goddamn defense by now yeah yeah how many years has it been everything but nothing works if locus want to come up they come up i used to have nightmares about those looks like we need to split up oh i get to choose i get right are you choosing no well i'm picking so do you want to take the left or right time.
So it's fair!
Left or right!
Player two deserve rights too!
I don't know, you pick Mr. Player One.
You think you have the right to pick.
This is why I'm giving you the right.
Wow, you're so generous.
I can't believe Player One is giving me a lowly player two.
right yes i'm giving you an option like to take the left or take the right i would like to go the right side mr player one do i actually can i have okay guys we're going left oh
it's like when you know like siblings would be like i want to play mario card and you give them an unplug controller oh wait we're splitting split like that what the fuck oh my it's like really like you sent me to die
there's nothing I'm fighting I'm literally fighting right now I might die you literally sent me to the area where there is I got you I got you I'm here over here yeah wait you're behind them yeah yeah I'm good how is he so tanky i'm still shooting this one person okay he's dead i was just dude i shot this one guy this entire game i hear you fighting on the other side lock yeah please kill that guy thank you don't worry i got you he's off the thing there we go i did it you can deal with the rest of him i'm gonna use the bathroom there's toilets here nice Wait,
there's toilets for the locusts?
The locust needs to poop?
They live on the ground.
Yeah, why did you just poop on the ground?
Why do you need toilets for it?
Although I opened the door for you.
You're so kind.
I know.
I feel like you might as well just unplug my controller too.
We'll do it.
I just don't deserve.
I just don't deserve to play, apparently.
Okay, how the fuck do we get rid of?
of this guy that that's my question right now yeah you just slowly head closer I'll get out I'll give suppressing fire take him out first hey I'm suppressing fire I don't know how to get rid of that guy I'll rotate him okay you rotate you flank flanking take the shot you can't angle I got it I took the shot You're not seeing your wife tonight.
All right.
Let's see.
Oh, we did it.
Get rotated.
Someone get on that Troika.
Wait, get on that gun.
Yeah, get on the gun.
You get on it.
I'm stuck in this window.
I got the window.
I got the high ground.
Oh my god, none of us got it.
none of us got the oh you got it okay you got it i don't even have to waste my ammo you're gonna do that what the sound effect is fucking ear rape was that like our first headshot okay i'm gonna save kim i'm gonna save the rock mr kim you're rock johnson there you go i'm coming back I got my high ground.
Oh, we did it.
That was the first headshot we've ever got as a team.
What the fuck was that?
I don't know.
I think it's like in the next area.
Oh, it's here.
I thought it was something big, but no, it's just one guy.
You got one guy.
Like, what the fuck?
I thought it was like a big monster.
I know, I thought it would be a boss fight.
Wait, are there boss fights in this game?
i don't remember yet journalists here gameplay yes you know what if we like just before for part two we just swapped the casual gameplay don't tell anyone it's like wow you guys are so good wow how did that happen we just don't tell anybody we saw the casual they'll be like wow they're gaming oh my god they're right they're breathing through the game all right you need you need ammo uh yeah i need regular ammo i'm like running out of bullets nice damn it where's that oh there's flying things now a lot of things gonna happen oh like what finding out that you're adopted oh shit i'm sorry buddy all right nice i wonder you can get like can you return a child what's their return policy yeah like what's their return policy for children because like you can return animals yeah so i was like wondering can you like return a child return an animal in fact yeah yeah i return my fish yeah when you adopt a dog you know it's just ain't right i returned my fish because it was not fit and don't be
asking for a friend okay but like i'm just curious like can you like like you know adopt not shop you know but like uh yeah i mean i don't think that that shop applies to children no key that but like i'm saying like Okay, so, you know, how many times can you return,
like, children, until they, like, ban you from the orphanage?
That's what I'm wondering.
All clear.
Until they're, like, you know, what if you're just, you're trying up different children and see which one fits?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
No, like, trying, like, see what fits the family, you know?
Maybe the vibes don't fit.
Don't fit the family.
What do you mean?
I'm just curious.
First of all, that's fucked up.
You cannot return kids.
For crazy.
Exactly, for crazy.
But like in the horror movies, you know, like the one with like the orphan where there was that lady that pretended to be a child and she was like a 30 year old woman, you know, seeing how she got returned several times.
And I'm like, is that real?
Or you can just return a kid.
They just don't.
Oh, shit.
Kim.
No, that's not Kim.
What do you keep switching?
I'm home.
i don't know i can't remember their days they're not that important to me you keep switching them up bro come on he has they're not that important to me they have not made an impact in my life oh that's that's kim oh kim's down yeah i don't know you quickly ran into four people that karma oh no karma you didn't even know his you didn't even know his name no i do i know i was waiting for you yeah i did kadoki only sees me she objectifies them yeah and is that really a bad thing like
okay I don't want to go.
Okay, I got him.
Oh, wow.
Doki.
Oh, yeah.
He wore a helmet and he died.
See you guys?
Helmets don't matter.
Oh, that's Kim.
So you guys wearing helmets are a mistake.
All the helmets ones die.
What's the point of wearing helmets if you just die?
True.
I mean, wow.
Don't objectify our meaty bed.
They have feelings, too.
Holy shit, I want to get the shotgun.
Wait, okay, I'm going to exchange for this area.
Okay, now I have a shotgun.
Now I can go up front.
Yeah, I got a shotgun.
Come in.
Nice.
Military equipment.
Always works.
Nice.
What the fuck is that sound?
You hear that?
Yeah, what is that?
Are you fucking starting a fire?
I've got the code.
No, I'm swapping my weapons just very fast.
Oh!
What the fuck?
That's so loud.
I know!
What the fuck is this?
Where are we even supposed to go?
I don't know.
I wasn't paying attention.
Search for Alpha Squad.
Oh, here it was from your fucking swap.
Can we go down?
Where is Alpha Squad?
Wait, aren't we Alpha Squad?
I thought we're the Alpha Squad.
No, wait, where's her?
Whoa!
Kim did it!
I think the game was, the game got tired of us.
The game was like, please, please play.
Yeah, he like fucking TP'd us.
He was there sick and tired of us.
Alright.
It's one guy.
It's one guy?
Oh my god, we're gonna get one guy.
Is he a good guy?
Can we let him die?
Oh,
wait, he is dead.
All right, how do we save him?
Wait, we killed him.
The Coal Train.
There's how he says it's the Coal Train, baby.
We let him die!
We need a hero!
Where is he?
No, he's still on his own.
Oh, he's okay!
Good job, Cole!
Wait, I want to be cool!
State your name, soldier.
Private Augustus Cole, Alpha Squad, sir!
Cole, as in the Coal Train!
Oh my god, the Coal Train!
He's so cool!
Where's the rest of your squad?
They're sitting tight over in the tomb.
That Choo Choo is the Coal Train!
device and to get you guys out of here well hell yeah we've been waiting for the chopper but the radios don't work for sir we noticed it's the cedars they're jamming our transmissions then we have to make those cedars our top priority sir agreed we need to look at that jaw that yeah he's immuting asap everyone has a great jaw on here the coal train never had brakes No stops on the cold train.
All the seed is.
You play for the Cougars.
Defensive linemen.
You play for the Cougars?
Oh, wait.
I need to grab some grenades.
There's ammo here.
You don't need it?
No, I'm good.
I have 600 bullets.
I remember you owe me 20 bucks.
He's an OG mure.
He owe me 20 bucks, dog.
He mused before he was cool.
I think the cold train knows where to go.
Nicole train Oh my god Why can you hear that I don't understand Yeah I know I was like How come I can hear that From your fucking headset What the fuck He threw a wrench at me Did you see that?
It was fix yourself You're looking at the wrong thing Probably Hold here Jack Decloke and rip this door He literally threw a wrench at me He's like You fix this Oh I'm gonna stand here this tiny rock will protect me Oh shit is that Cedar my ear bone
Okay, who's Jack?
My ears
Jesus Christ I got an achievement.
I don't know the streams like I'm just fucking yeah it's like yeah yeah I'm gonna use the normal gun I'll waste my shotgun on these guys okay I got the front you get the back don't worry you can trust me I've never failed you once okay there's no more friend by the way so let's do this Nice.
Oh yeah.
Oh, it's easy.
Maybe we should play like insane.
Shut the fuck up.
I forget how I died like four times in the beginning, but we should play insane.
They're venting.
Um, this inspired among us.
Wait, what's this hammer of God?
Something smells wrong in here.
Oh hell yeah.
the hammer of dawn get your hands back in the fight soldiers focus what gun is this no it's not a gun it's just a laser get over here and take these weapons don't use them until i give the order what the hammer of dawn the lancers do whatever they do the hammer of dawn something what does it do did i just start hammering it's just a fancy laser pointed oh it's a laser pointed I have no idea what I'm...
Does it actually do damage?
That this, this, this, boom.
Oh, what the fuck?
Fire your weapon soldier.
So it's a fancy...
It's just like a tactical nuke.
It's a fancy laser pointer.
No, it's a, yeah, it's like, it's right here.
Catch the attack.
Catch the laser.
Okay, he's dead.
You think we got him?
I think so do you think we got wait I want to wait how do I how come it's not working on this You think that's overkill
I'm swapping guns give me a sec What are you talking about he said it was literally a fucking laser from space and he lives someone like gives someone someone breed with this man with this locus to create super children dude we gotta get super locus here bring that man sample over there
we're gonna eugenics him all right how do we get out here oh love you can't say that It's okay, they're locusts.
They're not, they don't have rights.
You're not human.
How do we open doors?
I don't know.
It's just the worst thing to problem.
Who opens this?
Are we soft locked?
No way.
Doki, stop.
I want to run away so far that we get teleported again.
Wait.
Nice.
Wait, shoot it?
wait wait a foot how do we open this okey please oh wait Kim said it Kim go Kim I like how we like we just don't know how to open we're just too stupid to open these yeah we're just stupid like we don't understand we're just hired to shoot things we don't have like we're soldiers so we lost her front front for frontal lobe never had one we were we were born to just shoot things we can't operate we can't that's why they gave us two people to be like our guardians he gave us these two npcs to like hold our hand
lab grown to shoot yeah we're grown in the lab to shoot yep
all right bullets you need bullets i don't need bullets i'm good i'm gonna take it in i just i just take i just took a fresh one so i'm full kim kim kim wait where did you guys go oh it's i'm here
i don't know how i got here what's that
um we got some more okay okay i already i don't have my laser anymore because i should suck I do got my laser.
Yeah, you laser.
I shoot.
We ungabunga.
We grown in lab to shoot.
I'm pointing lasers.
Who the fuck?
Hold your trigger down.
I got you.
You think it's dead?
Kim, Kim, Kim, Kim, Kim, Kim.
Kim, not a science guy.
Is he dead?
Kim.
Kim, Kim, Kim.
Oh, no!
he's dead he's dead i think he's dead i hope so no kim no the science guy
what happened to kim wait we're not the science guy i got kim oh yeah kim yeah i was like where is he we'll go this way i cursed him die the one guy that knows how to operate Gears of war?
Yeah.
Ooh, game drop.
Reloaded?
What's this?
I heard they re-released Gears of War like three times, but like they never re-released Gears of War two or three.
That's true.
How do we tell her?
What?
There's no Gears of War three?
I thought Gears of War 4 was the bad one.
Take the stairs.
That's the stairs.
I'm going down.
How do we take it?
Jesus Christ.
Bro, they took two shotgun bullets to the base.
Like, what's the point of having a shotgun?
They don't just fucking explode after free shot.
You need grenades?
No, I'm good.
I have full.
I have three.
in control wait there's a gears award five we are working on that problem yeah on route to alpha's position marcus's only shit
i need a lower sense again this glass pad is so fast it's so smooth i'm not used to it at all wait what is your mouse pad what do you use right now still the same
Hayate Otsu.
Oh.
Not the one I use.
I think maybe it's just ping.
I'm just playing on Indonesian ping.
I've been wanting to get a fucking glass fad.
I'm not used to how smooth it is.
I forgot that.
Yeah, no, it's Indonesian.
They died like two seconds later.
Okay, that makes more sense.
I'm playing on Indonesian ping.
Yeah, this is...
I forgot I'm hosting as well.
Yeah, you're hosting.
It's like, why am I not lagging?
Wow, I'm surprised.
Oh, yeah, I'm hosting.
There's only three.
There's a Gears of War 6.
Don't worry.
Kim, Kim, Kim, Kim, Kim, Kim.
Where's Kim?
Kim!
Let's go, Kim!
What is Kim doing?
What's Kim doing?
I thought he was going to open the door.
Then we can find the locust heart and rip it out.
It's the body.
The body's right there.
Go, Kim!
Oh, my God.
Are we that stupid that we can't even press a button?
open the door maybe we were grown in the lab maybe yeah we're literally like they took away our frontal lobe we can just shoot guns like kim kim yeah guns yeah yeah guns we shoot we just know how to shoot Fuck GMO meat sacks
There's another chamber of dawn thing.
Okay, you you have to you have to do laser.
I ditch my laser Last one.
All right, you got this.
I'll take you this ammo.
I'll do that
Fancy laser.
Oh, I'm gonna plunk a shoot shoot guns they die we did our job job done job complete job done yes my lord
that's three for three laser make pizza hot control this is delta come in i copy delta loud and three.
I wish we could if they didn't take out the original warcraft.
That's great news, Delta.
Stand by for Alpha.
Alright, we did it.
This is Alpha.
Where the hell are you guys?
There!
Oh shit, man, where you been?
We did it!
We got caught!
Well, that's great!
We're pinned down by Troika's on your rooftop!
Over!
Well, is there a chainsaw in my shop?
You're not going anywhere, sir.
Delta out.
Alright.
Find those strikeouts.
I can melee with a grenade.
Why can't I melee with a grenade?
Nice.
What's that sound?
Right here.
Look at her.
Wait.
Where is here?
Here they come.
Oh, shit.
I was not looking at the right direction.
Who's next?
Chop done.
Chop done, Kim.
Kim.
He did it.
all right it's like we see a button and then our brain hurt point hurting my brain cannot function that much we use fingers to not shoot finger can do other things other than shoot shoot gun i pull trigger gun go
all right oh here we go we'll fight golden wait with gmo with sacks is that it i don't even i don't even play that much of a warcraft because i play mostly for dota for you may what yeah the mod for dota What the fuck is that?
Yeah.
What the fuck?
What the fuck is that?
What do you mean what the fuck is that?
What is that?
Southeast Asian thing.
Is it like, it's just Warcraft but with Dota characters?
It's just Dota 1.
Why did I fucking grew up with Dota?
I never grew up with Starcraft.
Move.
Oh god.
Like Blizzard shit.
Dota comes from World Warcraft.
Wait, what?
Yeah.
Wait, I thought it was his own thing.
What is it like, right?
It's just, what?
Dota is Warcraft?
Yeah.
I thought it was, like, its own thing.
No.
Nice.
Oh, oh, wait, Dota was a mod?
Yeah, it was.
It was a mod for Warcraft.
Oh, I already know that.
Okay, let me cut this guy real quick.
Oh, I'm getting shot.
why i'm chainsawing i'm literally losing my blood
oh that's cool i'm losing ammo what a fuck isn't there an ammo here we just saw fucking i did not know that dota was the bullet spongy as fuck i don't know i feel like i feel like all the cool mods came from like the dota side like what was it the auto chest shit remember when when before yeah yeah yeah it was like dota chest and then uh league was like yoink they're like you did not you didn't trademark this mine now people don't have to know about that where do we go kim kim kim kim press button kim walking in slow motion kim what do kim what do we do kim Oh here.
I guess I'm just...
Oh, I guess we just...
Oh, they're coming!
Okay,
we gotta shoot these guys.
Is that it?
I mean, it's very dumb of them to just walk straight into our gun.
I mean, the music's still playing.
Is it done?
No, I hear gunshots.
What do?
Chop done.
We did orders.
Chop done, Kim.
Chop done.
This one, I gotta move.
I just wait.
We gotta move.
Where are you calling?
Oh, where do we go?
Oh, Kim, I'm following Kim.
I'm following Kim right now.
Kim knows what to do.
Wait, what the fuck?
You walked in front of Kim?
Oh, yeah.
You think you're better than him?
Oh.
Okay, nice.
Wait, where's the others?
Got it.
I'm flanking, I'm flanking.
The more I'm flanking, he's standing in the middle.
I'm a wingman.
Yeah, look.
I'm repositioning.
I'm getting an angle.
Oh yeah, there's another one too.
There's another wingman.
Oh shit, I dropped my other gun.
did i actually drop it no yeah i need i need bullets holy just 22 man 22 ammo in this thing the was that called an apex when you like reposition yourself in a different area desertion no no like in apex when you by the way guys we're originally supposed to play apex and then i found out gears awards coming out this week yeah we're supposed to be playing apex because i haven't touched apex in like years well not years but no not rotate when you get I guess it's one person gets a different angle to help out what's it called again No,
it's not rotating when you get another angle.
This is just get another angle.
Is that it?
I don't fucking remember thing.
No Not a flank.
Is it is it just not a repo?
Is it just called getting another angle So I'm gonna get another angle on this guy or some shit.
There was a turn for it.
I'm trying to remember apex terms It's just so long wait.
There's a god wait my turn.
No get off Yeah!
Yeah!
They are too off!
Oh, off angle!
Oh, we die!
Yeah, getting the off angle.
Okay.
I literally need it.
Okay, punch is hers.
I literally was like, get off and I died instantly the moment I touched it.
That's an enemy.
Oh, shit.
I was like, oh, that's cool.
They're warming it up for me.
Yeah.
I was like, I was like, yeah, look, this guy's warming up the gun.
You got, you got this, man.
It's a little harder when there's no crosshair on this.
Okay, I think I'm killing them.
You think?
I think so.
I never think, oh, there's another gun right there.
Oh, you're right, sorry.
I'm not, I wasn't made to think.
Sorry.
What is that?
You guys got this, right?
Because I'm shooting the people.
Hello me.
I mean, I'm on a gun as well.
Oh, you're one on here?
Okay.
The bullets are your crosshairs.
That's true.
I mean, hey, it's a tracer.
Jump done, Kim.
Jump done.
I'm doing my part.
We're in the pickup zone now.
We're out of here.
You have a trigger finger and a punching arm.
That's the programming.
Yep.
What's this?
Who flowers you, baby?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, group hug.
Baird?
I swear to God, they all have the same face model.
Hey, man.
They don't have bunnies, man.
Because they were all grown in the same lab.
They were all just grown in the same lab.
There was only, like, four different presets.
couple of mix and matches of yeah yeah yeah they have like four different only four different hairstyles and they just mix and match all of them wait bear the same voice actor for soldier 76 oh is he also gay
why my ears Really?
My ears, I can't hear shit.
I'm picking on my earphone.
No, Soldier's M6 is gay, isn't he?
Because he don't go fucking lower, bro.
Oh my god.
No, I remember there was a lot of shipping in Gears of War.
It's bromance.
Oh wait, yeah, you're right.
Sorry, bromance.
Reporter Fuchoshi.
Mr. will just say they're really good friends.
They're really, really good friends who loves each other very, very much.
Yeah.
They're just roommates.
Oh my god.
No, Kim!
No!
Kim!
We can't think on our own!
Mr. Kim!
No!
Someone saved Kim!
Cut off the head of the snake and the body dies.
I can't believe they killed the Rock Johnson!
That's not it is!
That's against his contract!
I don't think insurance can cut it for that.
Do you know the Rock has a contract where he can't lose?
Yeah.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe it would do that.
I won't be open doors now.
oh no mr kim i can't go on without kim oh we're at china shop why is there china shop here china everywhere inside the tomb and we need a way out of here like in my military base confirmed control kia
we replaced kim with fucking brian copy that well we sure can't stay here you're paired yeah that's right asshole question is who are you oh yeah he sounds a lot younger here compared to soldier 76 wait there's a guy with a helmet i think he's gonna die
grabbed man oh shit
why is he chained up oh he has like little oh he's like a little caretaker boom oh oh my god he ripped him apart Wait, that's a woman?
Oh!
In the vicinity, please advise.
Big woman.
Don't worry.
It's a dream for big, beefy man to climb a strong big woman.
Other helmet, bro.
They want Snoo Snoo.
Snoo.
Don't do it.
No.
Ow.
No, my teeth hurts now.
Where is Snoo Snoo.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, guys.
I'll hold her back.
Don't come back, guys.
Don't look back.
No, it don't matter.
Snoo Snoo.
Oh, no.
Smooth beard.
Holy crap.
You okay?
So, what's the plan?
Baird ain't moving.
Well, unfortunately, all we got to do is get her to follow us.
I'm scared, guys.
Go outside the tomb.
Big strong woman.
What do you do?
Quiet.
I think he's gonna bust her head there.
Don't worry, I'll be a hero.
Don't worry, I'll be a- Oh!
Wait, outside- Oh!
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh.
Where are my...
Oh, we have to back out, literally, okay.
Cool.
Where is the tomb?
How do we get out of here?
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, she wants to shoot.
I don't know.
We only know how to shoot.
We scared a big woman.
Oh.
Big woman, huh?
Oh, we have to walk.
Wait, does that mean...
Oh, is she blind?
She blind?
Oh, fuck!
Oh, you're dead dead.
Oh, God.
Oh, you're dead, dead.
We got snoozed.
We got snoozed, snoozed.
What the fuck do I kill?
don't move what if we don't move I'm not gonna move oh never mind that's a bad idea I think she'll know I mean I think it's the pillars oh wait there's a fucking hallway here we're blind what the fuck we are blind we got to to absorb with the big woman big woman covered our blind spot Boy,
I think you gotta make her slam that door, right?
Oh, shit!
Did it!
Nice.
Alright, there's another door.
There's another door.
Oh, we run out of time.
I didn't even realize.
We're time for Isshu-shu?
really was the brain yeah i can't we got to think for ourselves now we were not grown in the lab to think wait where is he is he coming to me or who do you want to chase is he still chasing me yes you're literally shooting him what the fuck
you're literally shooting him i don't know what what the lady wants I what can I say I'm just the more appealing I'm the more appealing beefy man
okay yeah we got it we got it we got it we got it yeah that's right I am dumb after all
All right, we're here.
Come on, where is he?
I'm in his, bro.
Where is he?
Hello?
Oh,
I'm going down.
Why is he?
Oh, shit.
We're one door away from outside, bro.
We're one door away.
That didn't realize, your friends.
Why is your ass beat?
You could have just...
Why are we hearing you?
Why is your ass beat?
You could have done the thing.
Ah!
Just open the door.
Leave me.
I volunteer.
Oh, my God.
Don't worry.
I'll stop it with my body.
Is he going to heal you?
Don't worry.
What the fuck?
What do you stop for no reason?
Hello?
I think she's on me.
Oh my god, she's just like...
He can turn.
Um, she can turn?
I don't know, man.
Whatever.
Okay, I got it.
I got it.
Wait, it bumped out.
There's like another one.
Did you see that?
There's another one.
There was another one.
There was another one right there.
there there was another one there were twins i saw twins yeah there's twins are you one for you and one for me
all right come on where are you
please i love
oh i might die here i might actually die here okay maybe he'll look at you oh my god i'm sorry i just have the aura i can't i don't know the ladies love me i can't help it when the ladies love me i'm like that luigi you know you should be right the ladies what a Luigi come on get us out of here one door away all right here we go please hello big strong woman lady big strong woman I'm all alone here I brought plus one if you want No,
thanks.
I respectfully decline.
Oh, you don't want to climb her?
I thought that's what all men want.
Like, I have a big, strong, tall lady.
Okay, now what?
Oh, no, we do.
Jesus Christ, okay.
Satellite's on line.
She's stunned.
Target her now.
I got it!
I'm shooting!
I shot!
Oh my gosh, wait, she has ass!
Did you see that?
Yeah.
Bro, she's actually packing.
She got BBL.
I'm shooting.
Hey, she's dead.
Fucking hell.
clear hell this is delta come in
what a post it died we're here with alpha and we have the resonator
you guys all right okay we got to get out of here it's going to be dark soon so i miss kim
We can't do anything.
We don't know how to finish.
Is job done?
We don't know.
A job is not done?
Is job not good?
We'll never know.
We'll never know if our job is done now.
So we gotta hump this to the factory or what?
Nah, screw that.
I got an idea.
Oh yeah?
what is it smart enough let's move god damn whoa nco already that was fast what's nco is that the chapter no act two plan you don't have a plan you're just talking shit plan really lost the brain man the guy that thinks for us oh this is a four-player game i forgot because it's on console that's why there's four of us yep i guess someone would have been kim that died marcus this is on you hammer of dawn is offline what perfect what because it's in the evening now man what does that even mean i mean it's a hammer of dawn oh you can't use your gun anymore oh it's two players and why is there four of us you've got enemy units moving to your location they definitely know where you are copy that great sonny's off oh god wait left path or right path um left i don't even know what's left sounds sounds left looks like there's high ground someone quick bear and i will go left you two take right oh it's a split thing again god damn i'm on the right guess i fuck me right who cares what i want Who
cares what player two wants, right?
Who cares about what I want?
It's all about player one.
All right.
Little bro.
Player two's just a little bro.
The fake controller little bro.
Yeah.
The unplugged controller.
I'm just a sad character.
I'm a cutscene.
Oh!
No!
Remy!
Damn.
That's just...
That's perfect.
I'm instead.
What?
That's crazy.
I forgot about that.
Wait for...
You died in my game!
Oh, but when I die, you get to keep playing!
Like...
What?
You died in the...
I had the fucking replay Everything That's Yeah Yeah that's that's that Oh yeah That that That's why That's why I get rights That's why That's why that's the That's okay I got rights still Yeah I have rights Player 2 has rights What are you doing Okay wait wait I was happy he was happy i was happy oh yeah i'm doing my stuff too i don't think he sees me did you get him okay they're dead yes he yay i have guys i'm maddie player two uprising the player two right Yes.
Yay.
Wait, where do I go?
I'm stuck up here.
Oh, it's over here.
Never mind.
It's pulling back.
Great.
Yeah, it's gonna wait.
Save us for later.
Like a snack.
It's like bullshit.
Are you not here yet?
I'm below.
Yeah, you're not here.
Yeah, I'm gonna have windows.
You have high grounds.
Yeah.
Yeah, I got high grounds.
Wait, that's actually like little bait and switch because left looked like you had high ground.
But I got the high ground.
high ground now that's a key right i've got the high ground right oh you're dead covering i don't i don't even know where i'm supposed to be reloading i don't know i'm just shooting i didn't shoot oh where did i got yeah i tp to somewhere random i don't even know where i am how do i even get here don't worry we can regrow we can regrow mr kim regrow yeah we'll regrow him it's like how when the queen b dies they just make another queen they literally just grow another queen you would would you like clone yourself i would clone myself of course i would know yeah it's some some another day it would be me streaming and it's the other me streaming at some another day so we can take a break just where to go from here oh here oh there's like a guy with a big gun we're gonna die there's a guy with a big gun he's looking at me i need you to deal with this guy hold on i mean i could help you don't worry i'm helping you i'm shooting there the guy's not okay there's a new guy there's a new guy you
got walked over i was like
He actually just He actually fucking Just another guy took over Instantly, that's crazy Hey Yep Okay My ammo My turn He took his like It was his shift time Where are we going now?
I'm reloading Okay I kicked the wall.
They're not strong enough.
I could use a hand here.
We gotta get out of here.
Now if you got a plan, let's hear it.
Oh, it's this shit again.
Yeah.
There's a big gun in here.
Who big guns?
Yeah, I'll shoot big guns.
Stranded guys.
Yep, there's a camp up ahead.
So what?
Now our AI took his job.
The AI is taking our job.
oh well maybe he was better than kim what's all what's all that what's all that fancy robot with that yeah why wasn't this why wasn't this fancy robot working opening our doors it was so much faster but somehow it was slower when mr kim was around yeah i mean maybe job needs to be done i can't believe it they're taking our jobs i'm my job yeah yeah what was that was that ammo yeah i needed ammo when kick boom boom don't like that oh i told you what the fuck what is that
okay what the fuck my gun oh my god it's a heavy boom why does it no qte what the fuck doing for what oh wait he's dead no wait we don't have to worry he's dead anyway wait where is he wait no he just walked away you literally just stood you literally just stood and walked away there's a sniper over there's a gun oh let me take care of this i'm trying to boom boom boom boom oh he cut Come on pick against neighbor We could be- Jesus Christ.
How many bullets do you need?
I jam my gun.
Where's my OG gun?
I just fucking swapped my gun for no fucking reason.
It's fine.
We'll find it Well, we'll just find it again.
Rocket.
I have a rocket launcher now, but that's good
Never mind this is a waste of ammo.
This is a waste of ammo.
It only has like one shot.
I thought we'd give me more guy's hand i dragged my gun i got my og dude he's just shooting us through a wall i'm just shooting his hand then he'll he can't be a soldier no more we're gonna put him down because he can't shoot no more there's a saw rifle here you need that no i'm good i got my gun back for some reason it bounced off i was don't want to use that sniper rifle i don't want to get that sniper wait i want that how do i draw i don't know i think you gotta find other guns exchange oh what's that it's an ar all right swap your sniper and i'll take it no this is just ammo basically wait is it oh yeah it is okay nice actually needed that i don't get why approaching makes you run faster i mean it's just a it's just a repositioning you wouldn't sprint in the middle of a battlefield.
I just don't understand.
I don't understand.
I haven't been in war.
I would never go to war.
Yeah, because you'll get drafted.
We'll do.
Gee, thanks for clarifying, man.
Oh, wow.
What do you have You have the dodge?
You have the dodge shit or whatever?
Is that rocket?
Oh yeah, he's over there.
Nightbill!
That was a bit...
Of all the things I've said, that was the most wildest thing I've said.
Really.
I...
How is that the wildest thing you've said?
Yeah, I know.
Someone was like, that was wild.
No, I've said some wild shit.
Yeah, okay, I'll swap the boom shot.
there's a sniper uh i don't know what to leave i like my shotgun oh i'm gonna run shotgun sniper so what is this apex yeah i'm running shotgun sniper okay oh whatever this is one shot that's my problem Yeah, only one shot and reload.
One shot and reload.
Oh, I got this.
He lived.
And then I jammed my gun.
I'm trying to shoot him.
I got shot too many times, so I can't peek anymore.
Cool.
Nice.
I need him to like...
I'm trying.
He's looking at me.
Make him not look at me.
There.
Okay.
Um.
No, I didn't.
It was on his head.
I have one bullet.
One shot to make it count.
Make him look.
Make him look at me.
Make him look at you.
I have one shot.
Birds down.
What the fuck?
I have one shot to make it count.
Have him look at you.
I did it.
See, I told you.
One shot to make it count.
Totally did not, like, take five bullets or anything, right?
No, of course not.
Of course not.
Oh, God, I see what you think I have.
I would never.
Right.
One shot to make it count, boys.
Oh, shit.
He had a shot that make it count.
One dead ground.
let's get that yeah but you can zoom don't have to tell me twice yeah middlemost oh my god why did you tell me that no i shouldn't
damn i probably shouldn't i could have i i was this close to saying something really up how is this close aren't you a pro player or we're a pro player i can't believe it ever since kim died ever since kim died you changed you changed that i'm changed man you got it you can't you gotta move past it wasn't your fault dude it wasn't your Bob,
bro.
I'm talking to you, Vicky.
Hello, mate.
It was never the same since Kim's dad.
You gotta move on.
What has it?
What's going on?
He's drunk.
Where are the slums?
See, see, look at that.
They're drying rats.
Oh my God.
Yum, yum.
Look, rats.
What's wrong with eating rats?
Plague doesn't exist in Gears of War.
No.
Wait, we did 10 chapters already?
We're fucking breezing through this.
We did two chapters, we did one chapter.
What do you want about?
It's just complete 10 chapters.
It's all you, Don.
I got the domination achievement.
I'm going to let you down.
Hey, Santiago, what you doing here?
There's no news on the lady, man.
I'll tell you if I heard anything.
I don't want people seeing me with you, all right?
It's not good for business, man.
Give me that junk of yours.
Get on my head, man.
Get real, man.
I'm serious.
We need it It's me.
Sorry to hear you're having problems, man, but I'm not giving you my ride.
You did more to talk.
Wait, this is a six-hour game?
Wait, this is a short game.
I mean, back then, games were pretty short.
Wait, really?
Yeah.
I mean, two very games back then weren't $80.
No.
no it was not one condition they stay here yo as collateral we can i'm pretty sure cpus are 900 as well done i think the worst part is just installing drivers you hear about that new windows update that literally breaks your ssc slash hard drive i have it i haven't i haven't It's in my PC.
I never update my shit.
I disabled everything.
Oh, you disable auto update?
Yes, and everything.
And I am, honestly, I'm going to be honest, I am this close to moving to Linux.
You know what?
This is funny.
It says like, if you, so the one, the thing that breaks your SSD, it says that if you download something that's 50 plus gigabytes, with the new Windows update, it breaks your SSD.
And this game was 70 gigabytes.
And I decided to be like, you know what?
fixed let's let's test it out let's test let's test it out today what what is the worst thing could happen that's the worst thing i'm my ssd is fine i'm playing gears of what
let's go gambling a lot of locus between here and there i'm limit testing you got that right you need to hit our checkpoints with some ammo the first one's by the river so if i was your over there pronto you dig all right oh this is this feels like my home are you okay are you maybe perhaps not that's just like okay look if you just look at this that's literally my room right now with the body parts and everything it could be could be that's your lunch and dinner you know yeah perhaps you know i'm just a tv there just a little parley table here for a streaming the bathroom is that is that the bathroom right there that random no the the tires the tires the bathroom oh for the comfort right like yeah yeah yeah yeah good good good for your back yeah good for your ass yeah yeah yeah you gotta gotta keep the bones yeah keep the keep the butt cushion you know gotta look after the booty exactly It's the most important asset.
Yep.
So I only have...
No, I don't have a lot of ammo left.
Me neither.
He threw a grenade.
Oh, he threw a grenade.
I'm fine.
It's closer to you than it is to me.
Man, I shot it at fucking...
Come on, look at me.
I shot a propane.
I expected it to blow up.
He's fucking, like, sniper shotgunning us.
okay shot gunning and not pushing yeah you just like big mistake yeah yeah i'm gonna get ammo oh hey nice i should need that ammo too okay now i have sniper ammo don't worry oh i jabbed my sniper
oh god what the what I did it.
I'm reloading.
Don't worry, I got...
Will he live?
Oh, yeah.
Oh, nice.
Let's go.
Wait.
Oh, I can do it.
Oh, I can turn the wheel now.
I learned.
Don't worry.
You learn from the best.
They grew up frontal.
They grew 1% of a frontal lobe in my head.
Yeah, finally.
I'm unmuted now It's like those Okay, you know like those like clownfish Like if okay, have you heard about these clownfishes where like If they can't find a female fish the male fish turns into a female fish Uh, yeah Yeah, so that's me I like basically Kim died and my frontal lobe turned on Yeah,
you become Kim himself Yeah, I'm so I turn into Kim I Kim, Don, potato, tomato Yeah, when Kim is God, I become Kim okay i have this guy literally shooting me while i'm turning this here i hope you're shooting him i am do you not hear the sound of my guns somebody's fucking missing no it's just that the fucking difficulty oh god i'm i'm i'm jammed oh my god i'm doing hard work right now hey man we're both doing equal what the fuck is that I'm literally turning the fucking shit.
1 should be straight ahead.
I'm joking, bird.
Oh, it's bullshit.
Somebody here figured out the cold plate thrashbowl.
Now it's all, oh, cold train.
Cold train!
I want cold's autograph.
What happened to me?
Uh, no, the, the, the, the crows.
Yeah.
I was just listening to the cold train.
This is the bullshit time.
one should be straight ahead yeah you see that you see the crow oh stay out of the dark oh the cold i got frozen yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah stay stay the light tell us all about that play again i was listening to cole the adventures of cole where the hell are you guys we're working on it sit tight i was just listening to and i wanted to know about cole's day this was very important
Oh, oh, they would have told us this here.
Holy shit, what's wrong with the crows?
Franklin, Santiago.
Hey, it's dark now, so you better watch it, man.
The krill are probably out by now.
Oh, is that what they are?
They're called a krill?
They are.
And they just killed the guys at checkpoint one.
Shit.
All right, yo, Santiago, man.
That means they're coming this way.
Oh, there's a grenades.
Where?
Oh, yeah.
needs an ammo's holy shit of our ammo's what the fuck yeah i need ammo oh my god who's stash was okay we are taking somebody's stash right now hey yeah we are i need i need awesome you can take the rest i am full now i'm running like the most optimal build my sniper shotgun at 200 ping
rich you don't care who this belongs to we're at war baby there's a house eating apples you want that is i'm hungry growing a frontal lobe is hard work yeah big boy requires big meal yeah
don't worry flash sniper i miss wait no i think i hit it give me a sec i jammed my gun Sure.
There you go.
Okay, my ear, bro.
Holy crap.
When the headshot sound effects is just something.
Just turn the sound effects down.
What the fuck?
You know you could turn it down, right?
Everything is at two and one.
There's no turn.
There's no way.
Turn the sound effects.
I thought it was for that, Loki.
i thought they would leave i thought they would leave no they will not i thought they'd get bored all right watch out for the crew by the way thanks guys they're not attacked oh we have to do this again oh i worked so hard whoops i missed it keeps moving It's illegal We really easily you're wrong Why are they moving?
In what state?
In Dokilon Dokilon It's illegal to move when you're getting shot at You see from now on We need a life People of you aren't gonna like this Shoot the pooping tank for light That makes sense They kill us so we're doing it Okay I'm gonna show out my gun I don't think like I think maybe sniper shotgun is not the most optimal build.
I don't think it is.
Yeah, I don't know.
Maybe I got tested out for the longer.
I got rid of the sniper you want it.
Where do we go from here?
I don't know.
Okay, in front of us?
Oh, it's in front of us.
Oh, I got rid of my shot.
Let me grab my sniper again.
This is like one area where maybe I need the sniper.
It doesn't do any damage.
man maybe i can shoot his arm oh i shot his arm wait i can shoot his arm there see i got it okay oh he's just wearing a helmet and my keyboard keeps double pressing r so i jammed automatically after i reload that's fine we got we got wait how do we get oh wait propane yeah but what's over there behind us like i want to know yeah wait can we go through i don't know Can we go through?
No, we can't.
What if we let...
Okay, how fast do you die if you're in the dark?
Oh, fuck.
Let's go.
You know what?
Let's just go.
Are you scared?
Are you so scared?
You scared of birds?
Yeah.
Like huge cocks, especially.
Alright, I got the two left.
Please, we only have one fucking oven!
Get out!
I'm here!
We have one oven to share with us.
Wait, where's the next one?
Oh, it's over there.
Damn.
There's not propane right here.
There's a left.
We'll move through the building.
Okay, I'm going to kill this one guy, though.
Look, like, this guy.
He doesn't deserve to see his wife.
Okay.
Does he have a wife?
Oh, if he doesn't, I...
to see his mom that that's crazy he shot me first it's self-defense everything okay his berserker away yeah he can't climb this tall woman we are going to get dysentery from this bear's having a hard time adjusting you know why is it a hard time adjusting we'll be back soon copy that all right kick that door open yep is that over there
they're easy oh yeah oh there's so much of them it's fine I'm reloading I am okay I can't look up right now I got I'm oh shit oh I did not expect to see that guy that was a did you get the license plate on that guy I am dying.
You're fine.
I am actually dying.
Just reheat.
All right.
Just just just a little.
Oh my God.
He's back.
He's back and I jammed my car.
We're jamming.
Not in a good way.
Just self.
Just regenerate your HP.
Oh, I got a headshot.
Boom.
Wow.
Headshot.
Oh you fucking.
Oh my God.
He's back.
I got him, I got him, I got him, I got him.
I swear to God, I'm looking to my left now.
Every time I swear to God, oh, I see you, oh, I see you.
There we go.
Every time I shoot my gun, I look to my left just in case.
One dead girl.
I swear to God.
oh my god bro fuck this guy actually fuck him okay i have oh wait the crew are killing it the crew are killing them yeah i shot the light i was like oh wait we should have done that wait why did we do that yeah i don't know my it took a while to grow brain cells yeah we're slowly becoming sorry we're slowly becoming kim why are you are they ever gonna Like,
oh my god.
I don't think so.
I'm just gonna leave.
Bye.
Yeah.
I mean, the crows got them.
I'm like one bullet out, by the way.
All right.
I think we all we have to make a path again.
Great.
I just shot the lamp.
Maybe we should have shot the lamp.
Maybe that was a bad idea.
Wait.
Wait, they opened the door.
Wait, what?
you shoot that i didn't do that no i didn't do that oh you didn't okay i didn't yeah what the okay i was gonna say why the did you shoot the lap i haven't taken a shot i have i'm literally lowered bullets do you think i'd be wasting it right now so um the issue right now is that i only have shotgun do you think we just got run it well the only issue right now is i have a sniper and a grenade you want to run it do you think okay i have the close range and you have the far range hold on wait a sec i think i think i get i get the vision here okay what's the vision is it not something ah oh you see what i'm saying yeah yeah yeah i hate to grow brains the frontal lobe is growing i can feel it you can feel your brain forming we will become kim out this way.
I need ammo.
Oh, we both didn't worry.
I have the close range and you have the long range.
Okay, I need you to shoot that guy because I can't do anything.
Yeah, I don't know the hit rate on this guy.
I don't know why.
Like, does it have to be red?
Yeah, it has to be red.
Okay, that... The shooter's arm.
The shooter's arm.
Okay.
It's all you gotta do.
I'm just gonna shoot his leg.
Just shoot his legs.
Whatever works.
walk up wait okay that like that is so annoying i believe in you shoot the leg i should stop jamming myself oh yeah what the fuck man bro i'm dead i'm gonna die i got it you who you who i did it oh there he's dead don't worry i got us i'm a hero
Guys, look, I'm a hero.
She just left me like that.
What the hell are we talking about?
We live.
Did we not live?
Oh.
There was a guy right here.
He got fucking, didn't check your corners.
You actually didn't check your corners.
You take it.
You got CS code.
No, he was in front of me.
He just bashed me.
No, no.
You got cams hard.
There's ammo here.
Hell yeah.
I don't need grenades.
Okay, we gotta hit your death.
Okay, I actually...
Wait, where is...
Interesting.
Can we not go down?
Hmm...
This way?
Is there a way?
No, I think it's...
Yeah, it's this way.
Oh, it's this way?
There's a path here, but I don't know.
Are we gonna make that or not?
is that dark yeah there's a light right there oh okay i have to make sure you're alive first before i do it yep you're like the scout delta this is control we're seeing hostiles on our radar near delta two's position copy that yeah yeah affirmative taking defensive action don't worry reinforcements are coming there's two beefy men here to save the world I do that what the fuck happened there yeah I wouldn't even get to the door I don't know how am I here suddenly yeah I was like who fucking we started that
bro see there's like guns I can steal I'm cutting cover here it's Oh, good.
Oh, I can't.
I can't peek.
I'm regenerating HP.
He's regenerating.
I'm regenerating.
Don't worry.
Okay, I don't have ammo for this.
The frontal load will grow with this one.
It hit a bit of my load.
I got regrowing.
Give me a sec.
Did I shoot that?
I don't even know if that's shootable.
Okay, that's clearly a headshot there.
Oh, I'm jammed.
I'm jammed right now.
I gotta use my shotgun.
Don't worry, he's close enough.
Oh, he's getting closer.
He saw I have a shotgun.
He wants a shotgun 1v1 me.
Bro, I have nothing but a fucking...
Are you considered finding more ammo?
Anyway, I'm shooting his arm.
I'm jamming in front of a fucking enemy.
I got one!
all right we're good holy shit what if i oh wait no i was gonna say maybe i should shoot the light all right i'm going on i'm going in i only have a shotgun please there you go i got it wait i don't wait there's more than one yep there was oh nice but there's an assault rifle here i'm gonna grab that actually yeah i'm grabbing their assault rifles now because holy shit i can't find you what try to take ammo you teleported me what the yeah let's try to okay i got this job done job done okay nice hey anyone okay you guys gonna see it it seems awfully dark yep shit now what we go to the red look stay here on the one side and move that light yeah Give me an update.
We've got locusts and looks like Kriller on their way.
Rill.
Can you hold position?
For now, but you guys are welcome to come back.
Anytime, you know?
Copy that.
All right.
Don't worry.
I'll wait for you.
You need to find something, huh?
Yeah.
Don't worry.
I'm covering for us.
What's over there?
There's like lights over there.
Yeah, shine that top light down to me.
hammer burst isn't right yeah but this is like the only gun we can find right now we are like i wish we were we are very poor okay you guys chatting here nice okay get me over to that building all right just follow me oh my god yeah wait i am oh shit i am okay good here put this is my cover yeah uh stay here right now see what i can do i'm shooting back
you're still getting shot at no yeah yeah there's still one guy there's like literally this we're getting one guide right now behind that cover he's dead no visual he's dead we go all right go heading over i'm crossing the big sea you're like no dividing the ocean for me
so i'm assuming you're safely across i did yeah oh is there something over here we have where am i okay i don't know there's a building right there there's a building yeah
what oh i did that oh i turned on the power yeah i was trying to get ammo but the game was like no oh no was the giant boat wait moses you're like moses Um, that didn't correct me yet.
So we're both in the wrong
Are you okay?
You know those crawly things on a fucking wall dude you fucking scared me Holy shit.
Where even are you?
I am I am outside.
I am just walking in the light Okay, I'm shooting this one.
Yeah yep All right, let's see where I I gave us cover.
I gave us.
I suppressed fire for all of us.
Okay, I assume we go.
Wait, what's over there?
There's TV.
Oh, it's grenades.
It's grenades ammo.
Oh, grenades.
I think I need.
I don't think I need you.
I think there's like there's people here.
Wow.
Oh, it's been sealed.
Yeah, I sealed it.
I did my job.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
I finally got to use my shotgun.
I think the shotgun is pretty bad in this level come in over Baird Baird, I actually need this grenade.
We need to get back there.
Oh, wait, we lost connection with the team You said you're okay?
What are they even doing?
We lost the connection to the team again.
Oh my god.
It's the fucking you got to look up the windows again fucking What anything i see that robin we can go there oh there okay from the inside okay wait how do you get fuck kill oh i can jump through windows yes we can i can't believe the other two are just enjoying their time at the slums then we have to do the dirty work we have to do everything some people get eaten by crows or krill you know yeah no i met the two other guys the two guys rare and cola
yeah yeah yeah they can't be stopped yeah they can't be stopped hey you state your name look at them fool-ass faces Franklin son us yeah well no shit I know what you're doing here damn it we're looking for chap's gas station oh yeah well good luck ain't no lights between here and there I guess your ass is doomed huh oh you Go in the house,
I'll run the lights.
I like how none of us have...
Whoa, Jack!
None of us have that gun.
We don't even have the chainsaw gun right now.
Hey, man.
I screw up.
I'll never see your ass again.
Because you'll be dead.
I'm going to kill this guy.
Well, murder doesn't hurt anybody.
We're committed so many, so what's one more?
Watch out, huh?
You get trialed for, like, one, for, like, murder is, like, one, like, general thing.
It doesn't matter how many murders you do.
Yeah, you still get a lot of years in prison.
So what's one more?
Lifeline in prison?
You're ready?
Yeah, you're already getting life in prison.
I'm dead.
Goodbye.
This fucking guy.
This fucking guy just turns off and on and on the lights.
Wait, what's this guy?
Was this a guy you killed?
Did you kill him?
No.
maybe i hope wasn't it
i don't remember well i should bring the shotgun because we're inside now i'm getting on the watch where's what did i do i'm sorry in minecraft this you're getting on the watch list so why because i said what's one more murder how do i what i don't think we're in switzerland we move We're supposed to break it.
Ungabunga.
Mm-hmm.
Oh.
Wait, the krill was allowed inside?
Nice.
I mean, krills are pretty small.
Yeah, how did it get in?
There's no windows here.
Look up.
Come here.
Just come here and look up.
Oh.
We found who the whip.
my roof exactly
oh my god i got tp'd again
oh my god oh oh wait how do you know oh there was a protein oh no no no no no no no no this thing is moving this thing is moving we gotta follow it that's all right oh oh it's not that fast you think about it oh what do you mean it's so slow i literally run faster than this there it is oh my god is this driving wait are we gonna be in this car probably oh my god okay you're driving you're driving no you're driving look at this place you burned half the neighborhood down and with the lotus I'm just shooting his legs.
He'll live.
He just won't be able to walk again.
That's all right.
Sure.
I'm gonna shoot him in the shin.
Then where's a junker?
That's Resident Evil style, baby.
Save ammo.
I didn't feel the job.
I figured that's your job.
I'm just over there.
We're where, old man?
Where do we go?
Oh, ammo.
Nice.
We actually need that.
Wait, there's a...
Oh, it's a rifle.
There's a sniper rifle.
Yeah, but I don't need that rifle.
No, if we catarize it in time, if you shoot it, if you shotgun them to leg and catarize it in time.
See, we literally have, like, a fire bin.
We didn't just pick him up and catarize his wounds, and he'll be fine.
Get in here.
We've got some ammo in the back.
We just took it.
Oh yeah, I'll use a long shot.
He might die from, like, infection.
But, like, that's the risk we're willing to take.
Locus!
Oh, shit.
Not the locust.
I picked up the wrong gun.
You equipped the wrong gun.
I equipped the wrong one.
Oh!
Hey, I'm next to you.
The one.
I got you.
Wait, I got you.
Okay, I'm going to go swap guns.
I believe in you.
All right.
Okay.
Oh, God.
Rocket guy.
Don't worry.
I believe in you.
Okay, I got it.
Oh, my God.
Wait, is he going to kill us?
Boom.
There you go.
We got it.
A random man got it.
Got you.
Wait, there's a boom shot.
Yeah, that's his rocket.
I'm going to take cover.
I'll take cover behind the gas tank.
Don't worry, I'll take cover behind the petrol station.
Surely I'll be okay, right?
As long as they don't shoot it.
That's not a safety hazard whatsoever.
I'll be fine.
Oh, I just...
I just...
I just blew up a fucking...
I just blew up a canister next to a fuel station.
Whoops.
Safety compliant.
Ha ha ha.
Yeah, it's empty.
It'll be fine.
Control.
We've got the vehicle.
We're heading back to pick up the rest of the squad.
Hurry, Marcus.
Locust and Krill have launched a full-scale attack on their position.
Shit.
Oh.
Get in.
Oh, shit.
You're driving.
Oh, you're player one.
drive either i'm driving or i'm the gunner good to go drone damn it get in oh
bro are we i wonder how far we're in i think we're playing i feel like we're doing this really fast whoa whoa wait we should be doing this on wait did we pick up the other guy yeah we took the old chat yeah no i meant the other the guy at the gas station once he even ended up our car or did we leave him yes oh we did we picked him up you happy what happens when i well what is this why am i using it's just a lady stop doing that that slows the car why does it slow the car
don't worry i'll protect this you can trust to me.
Where's the krill?
I'm using uv light.
Oh my god, he's behind us!
I was literally lending the krill.
He's slowly killing us from the back.
I didn't realize they're behind us!
Don't worry.
We're gonna uv I've learned about this in the bored ape shit.
Will uv like them to death?
Just like them bored apes.
Okay.
Like my one job.
Can't this shit go faster?
No, it's because I pressed the key there.
I'm trying to save us!
No, this thing ain't going faster!
Man, man, there's a lot!
I'm looking at third person and it is like so much.
I look really, there's some coming for mine.
Did you hear about that board ape shit where there was a part, like they hosted a party and then they bought like a...
uh industrial uv lights and it gave everybody like uh yeah like it gave people blindness temporal blindness why would they do that i mean that's what we're doing right now i learned this from
them where am i going i don't know no i only have one job and i think i'm doing it pretty well
And as they go the faster, holy fuck.
I'm not using my UV light.
Oh, I can aim my light.
You are aiming your light.
Okay, tell me, like, if they're behind us.
Because I'm not looking behind us.
Uh...
Look out!
Oh, my God, they're behind us.
They're behind us, aren't they?
They're behind us.
Look, man, I don't have...
Like, I say I have a third person perspective, but not the complete 360.
Yeah, I was going to say, like, I thought you have third person.
Listen, I need not see them behind us.
Okay, I thought there were more to buy.
I'm behind.
Oh my god!
I thought you were lying.
No, I can see them when they're really close to the vehicle.
It's like one krill.
You're scared of one guy.
You're getting one guy, buddy.
We're half of health already.
No, I'm excuse me.
It's a little bit more than half.
I'm stuck.
How are you stuck?
I don't know.
Why am I stuck who?
What?
Hello?
You have to be stuck in front of all the krill.
Oh my god.
I am trying my...
There are so many.
Okay, now we're under half.
This sucks.
I hate the krills, man.
Please.
help him step dirty how many acts is in this game chat what how many acts slash chapters we're in act two now i don't know six seven let's do this five i mean we're two we're two hours in it's a six hour game so we're like half almost halfway we're two hours in i see they're okay But he's okay.
But he's okay.
Yeah.
Oh, train.
Holy shit.
Okay.
Somebody just got headshot.
I don't...
Somebody just got headshot and he said nice.
I don't think everyone's okay anymore.
It's okay.
I have his gun.
I'm basically him.
I'm like, you can't see them because they're like...
My turret doesn't go that far.
yeah i'm like shooting him through the wall oh my god i'm like shooting them through the wall right now i'm gonna use the fuck this i'm gonna use no they're so tanky yeah because we're playing on insane not like insane hardcore okay
where's the rest i swear to god oh we did oh it's because there's like a the hole is there.
Wait, I can, I can steal it.
Watch this.
Wow.
Did I steal it?
I missed.
No, you missed.
You missed it.
I got it.
Cole is literally blocking me.
Okay, I got it.
I got it.
Did it hit?
Man.
Boom, baby.
It's not my fault.
Cole was blocking me.
The coal train never stops.
The coal train really never stops.
stops true true are they all dead i hope so i may not hear anything okay bro oh he just he just like his head his skull his skull is just i think he's gonna be fine he'll be fine there's a whole we'll just grab somebody else's head and reattach it like uh what was that movie called like that the police dog movie
the dog police movie they literally attacked the dog 10 yeah from captain underpants oh i don't have bullets i was just shooting my bullet list gun how the fuck yeah dog cop we'll just attack the dog 10 okay so i only have oh nice i did that i only have a pistol left
I'm just waiting for them to peek.
Oh, they're not ending.
Yeah, we did it.
Boom, baby.
They ended.
What?
Boom, baby.
Nothing happened.
I just hear, like, people dying.
I don't know where to go.
Yeah, I just hear people screaming.
It's all behind us.
Wait, what?
All behind us?
What the fuck?
Oh, shit.
Do you have nades?
Because I don't.
That's... I don't think we can seal that, bro.
Oh, oh, yeah, yeah.
I think you're right.
Oh, shit.
Wait, there are nades.
Wait, I got nades.
I got nades.
Don't worry.
I got you.
Don't kill him.
I did it.
Boom, baby.
They did it.
Hey.
Okay, there's one more.
What the fuck?
Wait, how did he live?
Wait, there's like pool pain over there.
Wait, he's still alive?
I was going to say, you're still shooting him?
Oh, we could have done that.
Let's move out.
Well, where did that come from?
I shot that propane.
I was like, oh, we could have just did that.
We could have done that, huh?
Yeah, well, growing a frontal lobe, as you said.
It's relatively different.
It grew!
It was, it was, look, I am on 200 ping, okay?
I need a static boost.
Growing up propane.
Don't worry, we'll just get a refill of ammo.
I was like, wondering, I was like, why is there four propane there?
What would that be for?
Wow.
The cutscenes are made so fucking loud.
I can't even hear you in shit.
Wow.
Looks like we're walking.
Are you kidding me?
No!
These things were made for walking.
It was made for shooting.
I guess we're walking.
There's clearly a fucking road.
Our vehicle is VOA.
We're now on foot.
Please advise.
Copy that Delta.
The pumping station lift is offline.
Oh, so we don't get refilled ammo, by the way.
What?
We still don't have ammo.
Let's go.
You still don't have ammo.
Yeah, I barely have.
I have, I just have sniper and pistol.
Shit.
But you go first.
I don't have any log range.
I mean, short range.
You just need the right parts.
All right.
It seems like a nice place.
Does it?
It seems like nice.
You know, we're one with nature.
Clearly nothing bad will happen here.
There's literally a fucking mine right there on the left.
Where?
Right there on the right.
That's not a mine.
That's an oil rig.
Whatever, yeah.
Look, man, I can't see.
What do you mean, it's literally right next to us?
How do you not see that?
I didn't see the ocean, I go like.
Oh, yeah, the fucking water?
Yeah.
I didn't see the water.
It didn't fucking like enter the view range.
Alright, we'll just go in here.
Wait, what's this factory?
What the hell is that with me?
Means they glow in the dark.
Can we shoot it?
Yeah, they do.
you can't shoot it why i don't know maybe i'll snipe it done i thought i could snipe it it was they were just fucking climbing for free jesus christ is cutscene after one open that door it was 2006 it was all cutscenes right won't work these doors are too thick you don't know that he can do it go jack control this is delta we're at the factory but the entrance is blocked Copy that,
Delta.
Oh, you heard the wreck.
I don't see any other options on my screen.
All right.
This will go faster if we split up.
Cole, Baird, you head that way.
We'll head right.
Radio us when you find an entrance.
Oh, man.
I don't know.
That sounds like a bad idea.
I'll be sure to take that under advisement, Cole.
Now move it.
Yes, sir!
How come he didn't listen to the Cole train?
He knows what he's talking about.
You're a leader, Coltrane.
But it's...
He hurt his feelings.
You're an asshole.
I think Marcus is not a good guy.
Shoot your lit knees.
Marcus is a dick.
Yeah, Marcus is an asshole.
Who made him leader?
We're all stupid.
We were all grown in the same lab.
Who let you decide?
oh nice you took the wrong gun i took the wrong gun where's my other gun wait what happened to my other gun it disappeared wait what happened see that what happens to me i fucking picked up my other guy i had 400 ammo in my other gun no it disappeared no it disappeared what did the
He disappeared!
I think I got 400 bullets and then it was gone.
Where did you go?
I just nabbed some ammo.
They like fucking fell down to the ground.
I literally got...
I don't know.
Have you seen that CSGO clip where they were playing rank and then like the entire team just fell down the like the floor?
What?
Yeah, it was like some ranking and they were...
We started the game, and they all just disappeared under the floor while they were rotating.
I was like, what the fuck?
That's goofy shit.
Wait, how did you get through?
Oh my God, TPed.
I was like, how did you get through the gate?
I'm dead.
Oh, God.
There's so many of them.
They blow up.
They did.
Yeah.
I was literally like, how did you get through the gate?
I mean, what gate?
There was a gate in front of, you were like past the gate, and I was just watching you.
It's TP me.
Nah.
You've seen things.
Okay.
Oh my god, I wish I had my shotgun.
Right now.
I wish I had my other gun.
Hey, burst fire means you're saving more ammo.
CSO go to where they, apparently it was like a new map that got released or something in CS, CS2 and then like, and they just like, they just like fell through the ground.
it's the same shit it just rotates what the fuck yeah why did you go that way are you stupid no i'm just curious oh that's just an excuse for when you do the wrong thing i'm learning by doing wrong whoa find an entrance to the factory where the fuck is it where is the entrance just that's what i want to know it's here oh i think it's here oh yeah hello
i guess it was not there are we just dumb right now or what i mean we're both grown in the same oh we're both grown in the same lab there's a button right there wow we did it yay power is on man yeah but where does that open what does that do you oh there's another button there's another button we walked past all of it wow okay there was a fucking did you just walk past it yeah oh oh yeah go up yeah oh wait there was ammo right there underground bye ammo it's enemy territory i mean it's bad enough when we're fighting these things outside in broad daylight.
But underground in the dark?
We're not underground.
Yeah.
We're above ground.
Hey, don't tell Barred that.
He's scared shitless as it is.
Oh, we made the other two go underground because they're NPCs.
Yeah, because they're...
Even though Player 2 has no rights, Player 3 and Player 4 have even less.
Yep.
Correct.
Because we're still players.
What the fuck?
Did we just...
Did I...
Did we just teleport?
Yeah, we did.
Where did you go?
there you go good for you smart i'm right here yeah location right here and it's a dump control this is delta we're in copy that keep moving through the factory till you find the cart control room i'll use the carts to get you to the mine delta let's not waste any time meeting up let's just find that control room yeah player two is a second class players three and four don't Yep,
they're not even players.
No, even if they are players.
Wait, there's people, there's ammo here.
Nice, thank god he died.
It's Elvis.
Yeah, Elvis.
It's Elvis Presley.
How'd you know that?
Because he died in the toilet.
Wait, he did?
You didn't know that?
Yeah, he went to the bathroom and died while pooping.
Fun fact.
Fun.
Sounds fire.
Is that how you want to go?
Poop too hard, you got a heart attack?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Imagine pooping too hard, you get a heart attack.
That's, actually, I don't even remember the car.
I just knew he died in the bathroom.
Oh, it was a heart attack!
Yeah, he pooped too hard and got a heart attack.
That's, that was some shit.
Elvis ain't dead, he just went home.
my eyes damn they're bright as hell my eyes he died on the throne he lost the battle oh you got ripped apart
hey i think i got it yeah bared you did yeah turn them off will you what never mind yeah this flash is rude it's so bad what the fuck what was that what was the gun that we came with nah oh nah that shit sucks pistol is better it does it doesn't do anything oh my god it's 2006 it was literally all cut scenes dip shit finally the rescue team what are you doing in here waiting for you i'm ready to go we're looking for the card control room where is it well you have to get down to the factory floor through that door but it's locked well how about the only survivor though who me aren't we leaving not yet remember when the games used to like compile all the cutscenes together and then release a dvd of it remember they used to do that they do that yeah they usually they like compile like all the cutscenes together and then release it as like his own this no shit hey ask me if you've seen any geobots i still need one for our junker no no you guys don't remember i remember the cutscene DVDs
no it's true it happened you're you're lying no they did that i swear to god i swear to god it existed delta 2 come in watch the vents roger you're not gonna believe where we are control could you give us delta 2's location twice the audio balance sucks like oh my god it's not directional that's the worst part of the guy yeah it's it's just mono yeah it's mono as and like you can hear that directly into your head They're like,
what the fuck?
They're like in our minds.
It's all in our minds.
Come on, stranger.
Am I looking on the grass?
Oh, hey.
He's below us.
Yeah, I was like, why am I looking again?
There's room for one more.
It's a fucking party down here.
No thanks.
Keep moving.
We'll see you at the carts.
I feel like this guy's gonna die.
He doesn't...
Oh, but he's not...
He's not wearing a helmet, though, so he might live.
He's wearing a hat.
That's true.
Oh, true.
Maybe he'll half die.
He'll get shot in the leg, and then we leave him to death.
Can we please just leave?
But I'm grabbing ammo.
No.
Grabbing ammo.
Ah!
Don't grab ammo!
Well, I'm with the stranded guy.
I don't know where you are.
I'm coming over.
I grabbed ammo.
Was the ammo worth it?
It was, they'd been, yeah, I got 100 bullets.
Yeah, you used it immediately?
I used two bullets, okay?
I have 98 left.
We're gonna fall, yeah.
Oh, I told you he wasn't gonna live.
Well, he's gone.
He wore a helmet.
Well, he was wearing a hat.
Yeah.
Just watch your step.
How do we know which one?
Yeah, I was like, How do we know?
Oh, it's the one.
You see that?
It's the one that's lighter.
You see it?
You know what?
Yeah, you see this one?
This one, I swear, this one has to be.
Wait.
See, I told you it's the one that's lighter.
You see that?
I told you.
It's like the movies, you know, the animation.
Like, if it's lighter.
Yeah, well, now where do we go?
Wait, I don't think we can go here because it's...
Bro, and this, the monster won't shut up, bro.
Holy fuck.
I think it's this way Try It is lighter, but that could just be the lighting I mean, there's no other way Yeah, go, go That's some Scooby-Doo shit Scooby-Doo type shit Okay, that's, this is fine, this is fine I think it's that one is just the lighting Because the lamp is directly under it Yeah,
go!
You're out here creaking out here creaking, right?
You're creaking It's just people screaming Just go I told you it was just a lamp I'm pretty sure that that one I'm pretty sure that is that
I was right though I was right it was that one I just went forward after I said that I well hello hello I made it went forward when I said that.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I'm smart.
Where are you?
I'm here.
I don't have a sniper.
And I don't have a shotgun.
Oh, help.
I don't have a shotgun.
God damn it.
Okay, now we don't.
The perfect timing is crazy.
Wait, we have to do this again?
Okay.
If we cut through here, we'll be alright.
I forgot the pathway.
Oh, there it is.
Okay, it was like forward.
Shit, he's gone.
Wait, can we do this?
I don't think we can.
I think it was like here.
Damn, I hate this place.
it wasn't there it wasn't there it wasn't there i think it's randomized no my scooby-doo hypothesis you good no my scooby-doo i thought i was so smart why did it be false
I believe in you oh I believe in you where are you I don't I'm on the ground I don't know don't know hey I'm running I'm running
Apparently a ladder.
A ladder?
Yeah, we're still at...
Oh, here.
Oh, wait.
There's a shotgun.
Oh!
Oh, I need to grab the shotgun.
Do not mind if I do.
Oh, my God.
Thank God.
You found the ladder?
Nope.
You did.
Okay.
We made it.
Wait, no, we didn't.
We just do this again.
Is it to the right?
I don't know.
I did the right path and it still fell.
This?
Oh, it is randomized.
Wait, it's different now.
It is.
That was like, what the fuck?
Yeah, it's different.
Ah!
Nope, not going there.
Wait, maybe to that, right?
Well, at least it's close to the fucking ladder.
That looks light as shit.
Is it safe?
No, no, no, no, no.
I'm running, I'm running, I'm running.
I know where to, I know where to go for half of it.
I'm running, though.
I'm running.
I don't remember where the ladder is.
I remember.
I got it.
Okay, we go to the, we go to, like, the right side.
Wait, how did he get over there?
I went, like, not that way.
Shit.
What did you get there?
Yeah, whatever.
I forgot.
I can't think because of this mono screaming audio, bro.
Holy shit.
It's a fucking friendly fast beer scream.
Okay, I figured it out.
Okay, never mind.
Wait, I think I figured it out.
we figured it out wait did you go center or left no not center not center okay trust me trust me not center i i don't trust shortcuts i don't trust shortcuts and i was right we did it legit growing a frontal no this is the back lobe now holy fuck memory we actually had like no brain in there sweet all right nice sweet Now I have a shotgun.
Yeah, I just got one.
I got one.
I think this is a shotgun area.
Yeah, I think so too.
This looks like a shotgun area.
Oh yeah, 100%.
They're fucking screaming in our mono directional ear.
Bro, I swear the mono directional is so annoying bro.
Oh my god.
TP!
I'm getting used to the glass pad.
It's still like, it's so smooth.
Like, like, I have, like, no friction whatsoever.
I love being constantly creating.
The price is kind of...
Okay, nice.
We got this.
I'm just gonna reload now.
Can we do it?
I feel like the fonts are infinite.
Yeah, yeah, I feel like...
Wait, it's not?
Oh, do we just survive?
Is that our mission?
Find a card controller, right?
room or maybe left side isn't this it no yeah is there anything there i don't know how would we know we don't know anything we shoot gun and then yeah we shoot gun and thing die we shoot gun and thing die is y'all done wait is it actually survive wait our door open okay how the fuck what happened open the door maybe it's mr skin and mr kim in spirit yeah the game was like okay they don't know what to do we gotta open this door for them mr kim in spirit you know can i hope i can't do this with you no i can't why are you opening oh it's this way wait wait wait what happened can crush me let go oh the oh whoops i draw yeah people were saying the snub gun was good but
I don't know.
Is snub getting naturally good or are they fucking or am I getting one guy?
I want to grab the ammo.
Is snub going good?
I don't even know.
I'm not.
I don't know.
I can't even pick it up.
So I guess it's bad.
No, it's trash.
Yeah, you fucking can't even pick that up.
All right.
Oh, there's more ammo here.
I'm going to pick that up.
Yeah, I'll pick this one.
I'll pick this one.
two bullets i need that two bullet a bullet is a bullet nonetheless okay nice i'm good let's go door well snub is good if you can all headshot i feel like oh we're at three chapter can't stop the train oh you guys look good huh oh we got we did it i don't want to hear it man not a word whatever you say man what about the resonator cole still in one piece you know it the train is so smooth no he reminds me of he reminds me of that that guy and the boys the runner guy what's his name?
A train?
yeah he's basically an A train before he killed his girlfriend
before the trauma sets in bruh I don't actually watch the boys you didn't want oh it's good only season one and two though season three just can't commit to shows you know season three is weird it's gonna actually season two was weird too okay let's see this okay you know supernatural um uh have you ever watched supernatural yeah um so it's made by the same creator it's made by eric cryptkey um so that's why you see like lots of actors from supernatural in uh the boys But the thing about Supernatural and the creator,
Eric Kripke, is that the longer the show goes, the worse it gets.
And he, like, for some reason, he really, really, really likes to put a lot of sex scenes in the boys.
For no reason.
It's like, there's a lot of rant.
Like, every, and season two, every episode, either someone dies or there's, like, There's like a banging scene.
Like, or like they add both together.
Or...
I don't know, I don't even know if I want to watch it.
Every episode.
Like, it was fine in season one, because it was like every, like, couple of...
Like, it wasn't, like, every episode.
Yeah, it's either sex and death or both.
So, like, at that point, it was, like, way too excessive, because it was literally every episode.
But, like, no, the car...
No, everyone's like, it was like that in the comics no the comics was like comics were like so bad because the cop the the material is based off of um the guy wrote the boy like wrote the boys because he just fucking hated superheroes so it was just like he was just a fucking superhero anti yeah like legit i don't want to watch the shows because i might get distracted you might get distracted i mean it's one hour per episode that's the thing do you do you think to do no exactly yeah but um the new season for it was like meh it just it was like it i just felt like the story was like got worse what the do we go where do we go i didn't pay attention to what he was saying i thought like cole could tell us where to go cole can you tps somewhere coal take us the coal train on the ride let us ride the coal train take us to the goal please
wait is this no there's nothing here what the fuck where are we supposed to go I don't get this I don't know goofy oh there's still the music Oh, I'm on the opposite side.
So it's this way.
I'm crouch running.
This is the other side.
Is it not?
Where's the yellow paint?
Yellow paint!
Everything has a yellow paint.
Wait, opposite side of the other axis.
Oh, try that side.
This one?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Everything looks the same, man.
How the fuck?
Oh, that's a door.
It's a door.
Boom.
Nice.
We were on the opposite side.
Wait, what the fuck?
Oh, Jack!
Oh, hey.
Wait, we can shoot him.
We literally shoot him right now.
Fire in the hole.
Oh, nice.
Boom.
Nice.
There we go.
okay that was a little stupid we could shoot him while they were slowly going down the elevator yep it's open oh shit control this is delta we're at the card control room copy that delta oh my god rag three i press button button go where button press what do you do man you You just need to get in your own cards.
I don't ask question.
I'm close to you.
What?
No, why did it TP?
I was trying to get the app.
It like dragged me.
It literally like dragged me into There's no prompt.
I thought it was like, you know, press wrong.
No, it just gets close and that's it.
It's like dragged me into the mine car.
Like I did, I did not consent.
It's real shooting time.
What the fuck?
We're real shooting.
What is this mono audio?
Holy shit in my head.
them like as long as we stay undercover we'll be fine right i don't know oh i'm not going the same direction you are oh we're not we're not we're not okay never mind we actually have to shoot them never mind i actually have to shoot them i have the slowest mine caught oh yeah oh excuse me it's still that she goes in my face you know i shot him I'm just gonna reload every kill just in case Okay,
this minecart is so slow.
Is it slow?
It's on her side.
Okay, my shit stops Ladies first Oh, my shit's going this way now.
Oh, see you later.
Whoa
What the fuck
Hello, what is happening?
Hello We don't even have to shoot the guys who are starting to shoot at us.
This is the crawlies.
Yeah, this is in first gear like we're parking I feel like we're parking our mine cart right now.
What the fuck is this cart going bro?
Where are you?
It's like beep beep beep We're like we're on the parking gear
No, it's going fast.
Okay, it's going a little faster now.
Oh no.
Are you serious?
That's actually bullshit.
Like, it fell on top of me.
Like, there's two hits!
Oh, I'm just going to ignore it.
Dude, I barely even had to do anything.
Like, the cart grabs them, and they die.
My cart, I, like, literally just rammed past it.
Like, what's the point of shooting them?
What the hell?
Beep.
I see you.
That's me.
Oh, shit.
Boom.
Oh, God.
Yeah, I'm not peeking that.
Yeah, I stopped peeking.
I realized.
I should not have... Oh, wait.
Oh, my God.
There's the rollercoaster part.
And it's Elliot.
Mr. Bones, wild ride.
Okay, that cutscene was a lot faster than what we just experienced.
That was fun.
Control, this is Delta.
Do you read?
oh oh we're split wait i got yeah i got the cold train let's go damn it i don't want to be with cold cool cool cool cool cool cool cool cool cool cool cool then move out
let's do this i'm out of cold two days without lost time injury four four days you're able to
oh did i not press the button oh we had to press at the same time you press your button i pressed my what why do you have people i'm literally waiting for you oh now i can press my button oh that was weird oh yeah wait wait my area is so like calm
My area has no enemies.
I'm just waiting.
Bray's not helping me at all, bro.
Yay!
Player 2 advantage!
Finally!
Bray, get the fuck over here, bro!
I'm already at the...
This guy don't want to follow me.
Where are you?
Where are you on, like, the next party?
I TP'd you.
I TP'd.
We're waiting for you.
What do we do here?
What is this?
Don't need to be the main character.
Yeah, move my platform.
We're literally waiting for you.
What?
Oh shit, what did you do?
Take it down, take it down, take it down, take it down!
I didn't do nothing.
There's also one at my side.
I didn't know anything there was no buttons on nothing you're the one that brought the platform up here's the one here boom
boom all right it's fine I'll teach you again oh we have to listen to this gotta do your thing don't worry I have one end have one enemy on my end which is crazy okay because there's like a couple of them here yeah i have to wait for yours don't worry i got you right oh yeah yeah i'm waiting come on yeah you kill this weekend and then i just walk forward Don't worry,
I'll TP you.
I literally only have one enemy in this game.
Yay!
I have no enemies.
Player 2 advantage.
Literally just one guy.
Who has like 20 HP.
What the?
Okay.
Mark out.
TPed into the sky.
Stand by, Delta.
I'm raising the platform.
What the?
fuck we're just tp'd are you tp yet look where did he come um dumb what what how did you die i what i dodged that i was just waiting for you on the other side now we have to listen to this now we have to listen to him talk again oh my god i dodged that shit how the fuck did i die up now we gotta listen to her yeah don't worry I'm worrying we'll be fine I'm worrying okay I can open door door open and have to wait for your fucking cut scene you pressed the button yet yep my mama could kill your weak ass wait he's what the is it randomized yeah is it random was that just got aren't like the best rng no never mind you still have to you you still have all the enemies i still do have i'm jammed motherfucker yay play two oh play two but i have two whoa wait never it is randomized i have three on my end I was not struggling this time.
I'm here again.
Better be alive.
Alright.
I'm ready this time for boom.
I'm gonna fucking frag it.
I wanna know where the fuck he spawned in.
Like, where did he come from?
On the platform.
Oh, there he is.
Wow.
Walker.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, please.
Please.
Call.
Call train.
Oh, he, your guy shot me.
I
know that.
He crossed the stream.
He crossfied me.
What am I supposed to do with that?
That was your guy.
What the fuck?
was your guy you that was your fault he was your guy that's illegal wait my door disappeared wait my door disappeared yeah i don't have a door on my head wait wait no i can't i can't i can break it i can break it oh my god that's goofy as shit oh wait i don't have a door i can't
crazy my door actually disappeared wait all my doors are gone all your doors are gone yeah that was crazy how does that even what the fuck wait now there was no enemies off my side there's so much now on my side yeah I there was zero enemies here maybe I'll TP you standby Delta I'm losing the platforms for you there you see I TP you I got you wait my platform here my platform got razed out okay i might i how do i throw this with my
he's literally he's literally just there he's literally just there oh my god he's spotted in baby all right i got one okay um i got it give me a sick i had like an actual unfair advantage on my it what is happening i got him i got him i got him i got him remind me to think on you everybody my thing the guy literally spawned on top of him pop it out sending platforms down now once you're in the line you'll need to find the pumping station and plant that resonator get it done before dawn what the fuck was that what is that even supposed to boom so we know to he goes boom he train go boom yeah
it's to warn us that his gun go boom it's good you know it's when like you're about to ambush you're about to do a surprise attack but you have to yell surprise attack oh time show time everywhere here we go right enough let's get this done and get out of Oh god,
the crills.
Oh, they're here.
Oh, what are you doing down here?
Go back to where you live.
This is their nest.
Oh, this is where they live.
What are they shooting at?
What the fuck?
There's a guy out there out there just buying.
What's down here?
What's up there?
Where do we go?
I don't know.
There's two directions.
Yeah.
Yeah, we just go here.
We'll fuck around and find out.
Yeah.
Hey, look, there's a Gears of War symbol there.
Maybe we go there.
Wait, there's five grenades.
The fuck?
Oh, we can't do anything here.
Yep.
Well, we fucked around.
And we found out.
Where do we go?
Wait, why is there a guy shooting this stuff?
There's things.
Where's Art guys?
It's our guy.
Oh, that is.
Oh, it's here.
It's down here.
Our guy's literally going the right way.
Baird.
Baird died.
He stood there when he's on.
We can't take a chance with the resonator.
Call.
Baird.
You two stay here and guard the merchandise.
You don't have to tell me twice.
All right.
Radio you when it's all clear.
See you.
Yep.
Here we go.
Being underground like just two of us again.
Nothing's gonna hurt us.
Except for these guys.
Okay, I need to bring up a shotgun.
Say so.
The shotgun is faster.
them boom boom oh my god what the fuck i like you yeah that that happened to me that right yeah and then he blew up fucking dude what the fuck oh oh it's like a water slide it's a slide that is so goofy what the yeah we just slip and slide what the what kind of banana And a real slip was out.
What does that mean?
I can go down from here.
We ran into a problem.
You and Cole are gonna have to...
Oh, nice.
There's an invisible wall.
All right.
Wee-wee.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, whoa.
Oh, he's throwing an aid.
He's throwing it at you.
This is not on me.
I reload.
I miss our chainsaw gun ever since we like got rid of it we never saw it again wait how come you have it oh is this no that's my I found it ever since I got rid of my chainsaw gun I never saw it again you'll see it again no I've only have oh whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa that's a sniper do you have a sniper i have a revolver a ball tack yeah oh nice headshot i'm gonna go with my shotgun i wish we had flashlights on our guns yeah like that'd be nice i can see sometimes so dark yeah what the oh my god oh okay i got blew up You'll be fine,
right?
No, you were not.
Okay, they were literally like right to our face.
Oh, my God, we're here.
Oh, no.
Okay, it's fine.
It's not that bad.
Your ammo, ammo, ammo, ammo.
Oh, yeah, nice.
I don't need that much ammo, though.
Yeah, it's a shotgun.
Oh, my God.
I'm getting closer.
Fuck this.
I'm just going to shotgun here.
He's got a shotgun.
Good.
There's a shotgun.
You guys a shotgun?
Yeah.
We double shotgun.
Let's do this.
All right.
We do this again.
Okay, you got this.
Do you want to get another headshot?
I believe.
One of us will get the- Oh my god.
That guy exploded.
Where's the fucking recoil guns?
Okay.
Next one.
Go to the door.
What's the door?
Yeah, what's the door?
All right.
The door.
All right, I see oh, they just slowly come up to us.
We can just wait Yeah, we can just literally wait Okay, slow and steady What am I stuck to I'm stuck?
What?
Hello, just go left go left, but you push you let me There you go, I got you I literally pushed you out games my ass man fuck sake regroup locate the pumping station fuck is that at least there's no krill yeah getting rid of that guy oh yeah nice there's still one more i think what the fuck oh that's the krill oh boom boom wait which way which way was Yeah.
Okay.
Boom.
He says boom, but he doesn't shoot.
You see that?
He doesn't shoot.
Yeah.
He just goes boom for the sake of it.
That's five big booms.
He probably only has a one.
Wait, there's an amateur left.
We'll have to find another way.
I don't have a lot of ammo left.
Yeah, there's ammo there.
And grab that.
Wait, is that the chainsaw gun?
No, it's a fucking shotgun.
Oh.
Got it.
Whoops.
Boom.
Oh!
Whoa!
Oh my god, there's a hood!
Oh,
they survived that.
Okay, enough with the falling down already.
There.
Yeah, just stop falling down, forehead.
Mm-hmm.
There's another ammo.
Nice, I'll need that.
I'll keep moving.
If you get to the pumping station first, you'll guide us in.
Deal?
Okay.
Yeah.
All right.
Oh, I just...
Oh, yeah, I was just using pistol rounds.
Like, where are you fighting?
Oh, sit behind us!
Oh, my God.
But they're so tanky.
We're fine.
Oh my god, not nice.
What the fuck is he doing?
Yeah, what is he?
He just went, he got a cry to die.
He's like, oh my god.
I'm preparing my special move.
Just don't shoot me.
We gotta split up and find that station.
I'm gonna split up.
Okay.
I want to go right.
This is a choice again.
So I pick left.
Okay.
Player two, one's right side.
All right.
I got the right path here.
Nice.
I hope we both do.
My path.
Oh, you got the, of course you get the ammo.
Oh, fuck.
You have an ammo.
Yeah, but mine's further away.
Nice.
Oh, my God.
Oh, wait.
Nice.
my lock and load bro die please wait wait this is your enemy you didn't finish killing everybody on your side dude he just won't die I killed everyone on my side all right we meet up yet no we're still Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
Your guy's shooting at me.
Don't worry, I got you.
This guy's on your side.
This shit's jamming.
Oh, shit.
Sorry, my thing's jamming.
My thing's jamming.
Sorry.
He's going to shoot at you, though.
Oh, you're there.
Oh, shit.
God, I hate these guys.
I hate these floating guys.
They're so annoying.
Yeah.
Let's do this.
I'm moving forward.
are you sweet that's better okay okay you might have someone that's coming from behind you i'll just say you may or may not have something coming over from behind you that was on your side i had i had something ran past me and i think he's heading to you no okay we met up there's How big is this goddamn bro?
I was spreading air.
It's not here to fight me.
Bear, you guys still out there?
Yeah, unfortunately.
The fuck is down here.
Ammo?
Just ammo?
Yeah, yeah.
I need grenades.
Oh my god, finally I needed, I finally got Lancer.
Lock and load.
Yeah, yeah.
I want any of that, actually.
I've been waiting for the chainsaw gun.
I'm running over I'm here I Can chainsaw now I can contribute to society.
There's people above you
Suppressing fire I'll just never stop shooting.
Do they need?
We don't need grenades.
I don't think we need grenades out of the way I'm pretty sure You sure yeah, I'm pretty okay, okay i i did wait maybe oh you think i did it yeah see i did it that's clean yeah i'm gaming sweet what is the what's the chainsaw gun saw called is it lancy i i i don't know i can't click to dog wait that's when broke back mountain what the oh yeah thank you for the red thank you earthquake okay we're on our way we guys spiders that's a big-ass spider that's just a giant spider never mind you know how like there's like arachnophobia mode for certain games yeah in monster hunter like numerous monster under you put arachnophobia mode like the spider monsters no the spider giant spider monster isn't isn't censored no it's not censored oh they're just small ones uh no yeah they didn't yeah they're like you know what small guys they got spotted you don't have to worry about that one they're censoring everything but the actual monster and he's caught oh that guy's pretty ugly he's seven wait how
How do we kill him?
You see, they're like, kill him.
But how?
Behind you is a lava.
But he's...
Oh, wait.
What should...
Oh, shit!
Okay, I don't...
What do we shoot?
Do we shoot his eyes?
I'd like to know.
There's gotta be a way to stop it.
I'm running.
Wait, what?
I can't even go beyond past him.
Wait, he fucking...
There's an invisible fucking wall!
Oh, maybe it's a mouth.
Maybe it's a mouth.
I'm just gonna throw...
Yeah, that's fucking cheating.
Bro, that guy's cheating.
He fucking put a wall in there.
Bro, this death...
Oh, wait, nice.
His dad works at Microsoft.
And he put it in a visible wall.
Hell yeah.
I don't know.
I think I'm doing so.
Okay, you killed him.
I'll kill this guy.
I think I'm hitting him.
I can't tell.
I mean, if it's the crosshair is not red, I'm assuming I'm not hitting him.
No, I did.
I did.
When he left, yeah.
I'm doing it.
I'm slowly backing up.
Yeah, he's a Nepo crab.
I'm shooting his stomach too.
Begun!
A Nepo crab!
Okay.
Smash it.
Smashable.
How do I smash it?
I would like to know.
Yeah, how do I...
Um...
I'm gonna throw meat on it.
Whatever I'm shooting it is shoot smash.
The shoot equals smash.
Oh shit.
Oh, he's smashing.
Oh, I did it by doing nothing at all He needs to smash the area.
Okay Do you smash everything?
Okay, you need to smash this probably gonna die here.
There you go.
You just need to smash this part There you go There I smashed it.
I think we're just pissing it off.
I smash everything?
You need to stand on the area maybe?
I mean I can stand here again.
He's already smashed it.
Is it probably not smashing it?
Oh, there you go.
We just have to smash it again.
There you go.
Goodbye, Nepo crab.
works at you think he's a second generation Microsoft worker I
don't have I have no idea how much I have face balm just in time I can't believe we missed this cool still got the resonator rooted suited and ready to get executed goodbye crab sounds coming up soon let's move maybe i'll wrap up after the next chapter yeah once we reach the check chapter i mean i think we're halfway right we're halfway and i and i need my lunch yeah yeah i need dinner too oh hey there they are yeah and then next week we can just finish it
do a long stream and finish this game and then maybe in 10 years they'll release gears of war 2 or maybe re-release gears of war 1 again they re-release gears of war 1 in like 5 years it'll be like gears of war 1 remaster remastered remastered remastered of the remastered remake remastered just everything at this point checkpoint
Hey Marcus, how much do you think I'll let him really close to what holy shit.
I don't think I can count that high Need ammo ammo.
Yeah, and I'm running out of shotgun ammo too I saw something try using the shotgun.
It's just not for me.
I was using a shotgun for the crab There's nothing over on this side.
There's nothing here.
Yeah, I was gonna say it.
You want me to live there?
What the fuck?
Yeah, why did it make us go?
They literally baited us.
What is that even for?
Oh, there's gonna be enemies here.
There's so much cover.
Oh, for sure.
Wait, no?
Why would they put so much cover here?
There's gonna be like...
Oh, right here.
Boom.
Okay, here's the plan.
Dom, we're going straight in.
Cole, Baird, you two flank right, provide support.
Above all, protect that resonator.
You got it?
Oh, did you hear in Overwatch?
you can get banned for someone got banned for seeing noob they like reverted the ban today but like someone literally got banned in Overwatch for seeing noob in chat and then apparently it even works if you put question mark if you put question mark it also is a ban that's a flag yeah something bad you for what the fuck was that looks like they upgraded so once like they died here so many times on insane Yeah,
but we're eating moves.
I think so they know something's up.
Yeah, even when you're invisible.
No, I think you just need to go up there Yeah, even when you put like question marks, you also get bad Hey That's not for you You just can't be talked got PMA PMA Oh, yeah, oh shit, I headshot Yep, um, they They they went boom, but they didn't say boom,
but like they killed me in one hit They actually killed me in one hit Thank you for the raid.
Thank you.
Freak me out bro.
What the hell's that sound?
It's just the wind It's just the wind right when's the last time?
Yeah, people saying that they are one shot What the weapon is that one that those aren't drones oh shit They upgraded.
You think they know what we're doing?
Well, we're not here to sell cookies.
I'm a little concerned about these guys.
They're a little strong.
I don't...
I'll wait.
They're very strong.
Yeah, they're very strong.
Maybe not just a little.
Are you up there already?
Uh, not yet.
I feel like it's saved now.
Okay, I didn't...
I didn't think they know how to come downstairs.
I was so surprised.
I thought they were confined in that area.
How is I supposed to know they can go down?
Oh, they're explosive arrows.
Wait, that's cheating.
Jesus Christ.
Okay, I'm bringing my shotgun out.
Okay, nice.
Oh.
In front of us.
I wish I could ping.
I'm not peeking.
All right.
We're good.
Why can't we use their explosive arrows?
Can we?
No, we can't.
We can?
Yeah, I heard they're...
I mean, it's explosive arrows.
Is it good or bad?
I'll try that right now.
There's no crosshair.
Oh, there's no crosshair.
Never mind.
Oh, never mind.
It's a fucking projectile.
It's a projectile like the grenade.
Just Hanso it.
Hanso!
Simple geometry.
Look at that!
It's simple geometry.
Oh my god.
Wait, did he blow himself up?
Oh no, it was you.
No, I fucking...
Yeah.
You hit him.
Oh, wait.
Wait, where's the last guy?
Wait, why do you do that?
I'm grabbing shotgun ammo.
Wow.
You're just fucking running around each other.
Bring it.
Where are they?
Are they all dead?
oh wait no no there's one guy right here he's just letting me backshot him there wait red's dead yeah where is he that's what i don't know where did he die oh they're on they're on the ground now guys how did he get this thing is fun how did he get over there is it like a bow check huh is it like a bow check if you say we'll check with the trajectory alignment yeah sure um hit him up where do we go now what the carry lancer what the fuck where do you go now i'm going forward secure secure the pumping station so i guess most of them hasn't died yeah i think there's still there has to be someone still alive i'm gonna go whisper oh yeah there's there is just one guy Oh,
wait, wait, he's shooting at me.
He's shooting at me.
He literally did, like, he shot me from 20 miles away.
Nice job.
Okay, time to go home.
Bear, you set up the resume.
Get that over there.
Oh, shit, jammed.
Just reloading on my gun, just in case.
Sweet.
Nice.
Yay!
Goodbye, Bear.
He lives.
Wait,
are we at endgame?
Wait, can we just beat this game now?
I don't even know.
I've never played this game.
I only watched my dad play it.
I don't know how many acts there is.
There's no way.
I think we're just halfway.
I'm pretty sure we're halfway.
We're only three hours in.
And most of it is goofing off.
Oh, two acts left.
Oh, you can do that next week.
We're clear.
Two acts left.
Yeah.
And let's wrap it.
Let's wrap it here.
Yeah, after this cutscene.
Yeah.
So we going back to base.
I guess so.
This feels like an end game cutscene.
Food, man.
hot food nice want some hot dogs damn i want a hot dog now yeah what what do you mean we still get pat we need to pat this game for two more hours let's go what did they do
who could have seen this coming
it didn't collapse it yeah oh Resonator didn't deliver the goods according to Anya.
We're missing data on hell.
I don't know most of the network We need a hundred a hundred resonated so what we'll use this instead.
I'll use it to smash your teeth in how about that Shut up and look at it
Look those are locust tunnels Phoenix.
You know, I'm right Where did you find that it popped on screen when I hacked in the files were there You should just pour like molten lava in there.
You're doxing the...
Oh my god, you're doxing the locust!
Yeah.
Give me a zero point on that data.
Sir, well, it came from East Barricade Academy.
From his father's house, specifically.
Whose father?
Sergeant Phoenix, sir.
can still find your way back home phoenix yes sir reroute those choppers lieutenant
who's that oh who's this random man oh god well i guess we don't care oh the transmission i hated neck things oh they like twisty necks oh they yeah i was like who is he well we i guess we don't care about him him well he wore a helmet yeah he wore a helmet oh seven helmet guy don't wear a hat or a helmet this type of game yeah helmets don't do anything apparently yep damn
well how we did it swear to god if they just oh my god act for it Yo, we are really close to you.
Better cutscene, yay!
So much cutscenes.
I think, like, if we remove all the cutscenes, we would have played this game for, like, two hours.
Yeah, legit.
I didn't think it.
I think the game would have been two hours without cutscenes.
All right.
I guess he saved, right?
Is he saved?
Wait, they just fucking put us in a fucking battlefield.
It's okay, it's okay.
We saved, right?
It's okay.
We saved.
I think so it's a checkpoint.
You gotta pause.
I can't pause the game because I have no rights.
You have no rights.
When I pause, you get to keep playing.
Correct.
GG's touches.
GG's.
That was fun.
Oh, I have died.
I'm not lagging anymore.
I'm so happy.
I'm actually not lagging anymore.
Very nice.
Yeah.
I was worried because I was actually reading the Steam Reviews.
I do wish to upgrade my PC, but today, My teeth says otherwise.
Oh, wait.
When was last time I went to dentists?
Like last week.
Wait, last week?
So I got like, like, yeah, I got like my wisdom tooth removed.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, so it's still healing, right?
It's still healing.
Yeah.
There's like stitches in here right now.
And you're trying not to touch the stitches.
No, it's hard to eat, though.
Oh, it's true.
Yeah.
Just eat like, I mean, I think, well, I got my wisdom teeth removed.
I just really just ate soup.
I've been drinking milkshakes now.
non-stop not even wait isn't that bad what do you mean it's bad it's sweet isn't that bad isn't it not good yeah oh wait oh but you can't have ice oh yeah that's true i was gonna say it doesn't matter because you can have uh ice cream and stuff i don't remember it's been so done i don't remember uh the stitches will be removed around first september hopefully oh you got the non-dissolvable ones no we don't have that here you don't have does dissolvable stitches you think I'm rich enough to fucking buy it I thought it was just I thought you meant by like not allowed like like dissolvable stitches is like where you draw the line in dentistry like I'm poor oh I'm sorry like like fucking four of it is actually having a problem right now huh but yeah all four at the same time wait you got four removed no only Because again,
I'm broke.
Oh, okay.
I asked for that.
I was like, estimations for like, how much is it going to be?
Like, I thought it was going to be like a grand or something.
Yeah.
It's fucking, it's like two and a half grand.
I'm not paying that.
I'm not paying that much.
For like all four, right?
Yes.
That does not include the checkups, the room and everything like that.
I'm like, what?
Nah.
I think, I mean, it's, I think like.
um even then like if you removed all four it would have been like so painful like it would it's gonna take a while yeah the recovery is gonna be hell i'm like yeah no i still want to stream yeah yeah you can still talk too i think like for me it took me a lot like i think it took like me a week and a half to even because i had two removed i think it took me like a while to like like be able to talk properly and stuff because i was just bleeding out of my gums well no bleeds so far that's good that's really good i was smoking nothing's wrong with it smoking with your wrist some deeper mood hey man okay man the doctor just said like 48 hours after surgery and i'm like i forgot while we were prepping the stream i was like oh i'm just waiting for my i'm just plugging my pc and he was like all right you know more time to buy cigarettes yes sir yeah he was out buying cigarettes while i was trying to plug my pc in like bro you're not supposed to smoke while you're wisdom team is recovered you
literally have 48 hours you you asked the dentist to be like oh when can i smoke again yeah he literally was like 48 hours he said 48 hours after surgery and so i did i followed it was 8 p.m and then i smoked out 8 p.m two days after the surgery you literally put alarm and be like it's almost time down to the minute holy shit like hell I could I could tolerate the fucking pain after surgery smoking god oh yeah the nicotine addiction yeah you know I was like googling because I was like wondering like um what's worse vaping or smoking or and then like like apparently vaping is there's more damage to your lungs than smoking I thought well like what but that shit's everywhere yeah i feel like vaping is like like everywhere compared to smoking at this point they're both yeah i mean it's just my opinion you know smoking is natural it's a plants and stuff right smoking is natural it's plants and everything yeah what do you feel
oh smoking yeah i don't trust nicotine i was like that's not condone both or anything of the short do not consume nicotine just has he's just he's just has an addiction i yeah chronic addiction don't blame it yeah yeah he's trying he's trying yeah because like before they didn't know you you uh because you remember when last time we talked you uh we're trying to quit smoking they didn't know that you you i did quit for two months for two months and then two months yeah i mean that's pretty good life happens yeah so well too bad huh yeah it's okay we could try again in the future definitely sure yeah yeah yeah you successfully tried i mean two months was a good run is that a record uh maybe yeah next time we'll be like i don't know maybe three months and then we'll just like if if my dad can stop smoking yeah like until now he just stoked about he did not do anything like no no therapy no he raw dog that's it like he just okay i quit that's it he was mentally strong-willed no that's
like wow that's actually crazy we just be like i stop now like and i believe it's been 17 years since he stopped and he that's that's very impressive oh wait you're next tangent you're next yeah i hope so yeah but anyway i fucking hope so ggs tangent ggs i'll see you next week i'm gonna grab some lunch probably yeah i gotta grab dinner it's like 9 p.m over here i'm gonna make sure like places are still open for food but ggs man it's fun it's fun playing yeah yeah I mean,
we have to.
Next week?
For real?
Yeah, we got finished.
What do you mean?
We're not waiting like five months to finish Pride 2.
No shit.
I need my spaces.
It's like, what if we don't be like, what happened like five months late?
Like no, we played it next year on the anniversary.
It's not when we started the game.
We just waited until next year and we're like, okay, so where are we in this game?
Where are we?
And then they were like, oh yeah, the second game.
We just like.
like watch a re like we watch a no commentary playthrough to figure out where we're at full recap no commentary no gameplay yeah ggs engine hope you have a good lunch hello yeah i was gonna say i just like i was shocked because because the dono came through oh and the tts and the tts was broken for a second i don't know why but the first don't know he's always broken i was just like i can't fix you alive what happened yeah bro was lagging for a moment even though i'm on his server i i yeah i thought he you just left there's some shit like the power i'm good i know i know sorry the tts is having a stroke i was like what the fuck yeah ggs tangent ggs i hope you recovered from the don't forget to staying up like all right take care of yourself yeah ggs now here you cover from the wisdom teeth stitches and have a good recovery so you can eat again um but have a good lunch man yeah you have a great evening yeah stay smiling yeah ah all right thank you everyone i hope you guys had a fun time
watching gears of war um part one most likely we'll finish Gears Award tomorrow, not tomorrow, sorry, next week.
Not tomorrow.
Tomorrow is, tomorrow is Silk Song.
No, it's back to Hollow Day.
It's back to Hollow Day.
Tomorrow is Hollow Day.
I hope we can play as much as we can for tomorrow.
We're going to do another long stream for Hollow Day because I want to make sure that, I think I'm pretty sure I can finish it before Silk Song releases.
I think what I'm going to do is that I'm going to get the, because I know, like, so you guys want, I'm going to see how far, I'm going to see if I can get true ending before, before Silk Song releases, but if I don't have enough time, I might just, like,
you know, get the basic ending and then do the true ending at a later, like, at another point, um, before Silk Song, uh, but we'll see how far we can go with, with just going through the, we'll see, okay, we're going to do all the requirements for the basic ending,
and after the basic ending, and then when we and when i because i know like because i was like reading up for it because i was like okay because i know some of you guys want me to get the true ending so i was reading up um like what i need to do for true ending and basic ending and like um you can get to the point where there's the basic ending but you don't have to activate the ending yet so uh yeah so i don't have to activate the ending yet so i'll get there um and then i'll see how far i need how much i have to do for the true ending and if it's a lot before silk song then we'll get that basic ending first and then and then we'll see yeah yeah and then we'll see like how far and then we'll see how far and then after we try out silk song we'll go back to um we'll go back to the hollow night um but it's been a lot of fun it's been a fun stream week this week um been having a blast playing all the different games uh we're gonna play sleeping dogs again next week as well we're gonna
resume the sleeping dogs playthrough um just yeah thank you for the super chat oh i got kicked out because tension left the game um um but i hope you guys had a lot of fun uh with tension uh today um what y'all want to talk about uh but yeah i'm actually really happy that i think we fixed a lag issue um i think we fixed it also guys okay i weren't i'm gonna say this after i i didn't want to talk about like why we weren't lacking anymore but because my manager was awake and like he was trying to be like just buy a new pc because you're just putting like you're just upgrading the same thing over and you might as well just invest in a new pc that was like yeah okay don't worry it's just a cpu i also bought a 5090 something
I waited until he went to bed before I'd say it.
I was desperate.
I was lagging in Minecraft.
I'm, don't keep playing.
I was so, I was so desperate.
I was lagging in Minecraft yesterday.
And I was just, I just gave, shut up.
I was like, okay, if I buy a new, if I get a new CPU and a new, a new 5090, then surely, and two more sticks of RAM.
I have 128 gigabits.
I think I have like, I have four sticks of RAM now instead of two sticks of RAM.
And I was like, there's no way I will lag this time.
I literally was like, I don't care anymore.
I don't I don't care anymore I was like I can't okay it wasn't just Minecraft I was lagging in Marvel rivals too so I was just like okay there's no way surely I'll stop lagging now surely my skin suit and it's just v2 studios and so it's just because like okay before I would man here was like you know you should like instead of like oh you really should stop just upgrade just just buy a new pc at this point just buy a pre-built because like at this point it might just be easier and i was like you're right yeah you're right and i went to the pc shop i was like do you have a 50 90 in stock and they're like yeah i was like yeah i'll get it it's like it you know i'm already committed i've already i already have like i already bought a cpu and two two more sticks of ram and then I already bought CPU and two more sticks of RAM and I was just like I might as well you know I was like I'm here anyway I'm I'm here anyway I did I was lagging in Marvel rivals with the lowest settings and I'm not
not in game though it was literally just VTube studio that was like lagging so at that point I was like I was like this is it I have This, this PC is so fucking tanky.
I could literally run a thousand frames if I wanted to I was like, I couldn't, but it's okay.
I got, I got a new CPU, a new GPU and two sticks of RAM It's too late.
I've already committed to this PC.
I
There's no way I can lag now.
There's no way.
I didn't lag and here's the why.
We did it.
We fixed it.
It might cost me $4,000 Canadian dollars, but we did it, guys.
Just a little sacrifice.
We did it.
There is a way.
Please.
Oh my, we did it.
Yay.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Don't keep it.
Just a little sacrifice.
It was like, ah, you, it's okay.
We did it, guys.
Yippee.
Thank you.
Yeah, yeah, Dokey.
Stick it to the man.
Just keep it.
Give it a super chat.
Thank you.
I feel it.
My longest run was six months and I relapsed due to stress.
Still trying to quit against the key value.
Yeah, I hope for anyone that's still trying to quit smoking.
I hope you guys will be able to do it.
I know it's really hard because as you have an addiction, it's very hard to stop.
So I hope everybody, I hope, like, you know, everybody will be able to do it in the end.
You know, you put just, it just has to be a right environment.
If you want to, like, actually quit an addiction, it has to be, like, the right environment.
Because when you get stressed, you easily, like, relapse into it.
Just like how whenever I relapse back into Marvel arrival is like I usually relapse when I have like the most work to do I honestly know I think I can actually make get all my old parts and Um use it to make a new PC so it's thank you the super chat thank you thank you at this point You have enough for a second PC set up and smarter Parts they give us a super chat thank you thank you Oh yeah and I have to buy a new power supply because my old power supply was not strong enough for a 50-90.
So, I had to, in fact, this is basically a new PC at this point.
The only thing that's old was this my hard drive, my SSDs and my motherboard.
Everything else is just, like, a new thing.
It's basically a new computer.
Yeah, you need, like, at least 1,200 watts, so I had to get a new power supply, too.
Yeah, It's okay.
Now, now we should, we wouldn't lag.
Now we should be okay for Minecraft.
I can't believe this.
All right, guys.
I'm going to head off now.
I want to make sure that I have enough time to get food.
Spud, thank you all for coming.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, pause to check.
Get them around to get that blood flowing.
And if you said for me, head to bed, cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.
Thank you.